Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So Leute, da bin ich mal wieder. Eine Woche kein Stream. Ich bin echt ein wenig beschäftigt gerade,
nicht nur mit der Arbeit, aber ich bin sinnloserweise wieder uralte Sachen am Spielen,
was ich vielleicht besser nicht machen sollte, weil das viel zu viel Zeit frisst und ich lieber
YouTube Videos machen sollte bzw. Stream suchen. Aber so ist das halt. Manchmal hast du einfach
Bock irgendwelchen ollen Kram zu spielen, der dir früher schon gefallen hat. Das ist wahrscheinlich
so eine Boomer-Angewohnheit. Wenn man natürlich noch nicht so alt ist, dann kennt man das vielleicht
nicht. So. Gucken, ob alles hier funst. Jo, bisschen laut. Warum? Weil Teams wieder am
Mikrofon rumgefuscht hat, wahrscheinlich. Teams hat wieder am Mikrofon rumgefuscht. Exzellent,
exzellent. Nein, nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich exzellent. Nee, da kann ich nicht hochladen. Das
ist ein MMO. Das ist langweilig. Ich mache aber ein Video drüber. Ich wollte eigentlich gestern
ein Video aufnehmen, aber ich habe den ganzen Tag wieder sinnlos Kreisel-Crime gemacht. Lul. W, HD,
XD, 4K, Ultra HD. Ja, Leute. Was machen wir denn jetzt? Ist diese Woche irgendwas Spannendes? Ich
bin relativ früh. Guckt mal hier, 9.14 Uhr, 9.34 Uhr. Ich habe echt ein großes Problem,
Leute. Ich sage euch das jetzt auch mal. Also eine Sache, die mache ich seit Jahren und die ist
eigentlich total Three-Head. Ich fange einen Satz an und wenn ich nicht mehr weiß, wie er weitergeht,
sage ich trotzdem irgendwas. Ich habe auf die Uhr geguckt gerade und habe angefangen zu sagen,
ah, es ist 9. So, und dann habe ich nicht richtig gelesen und habe einfach weiter geredet und
fast gesagt 9.34 Uhr, weil ich meine Augen, Boomer-Augen, weil ich noch nicht richtig erkannt
habe, was da eigentlich steht. Also ich rede quasi schneller, als ich den restlichen Satz im Kopf
vervollständigen kann. Das ist ziemlich dumm, weil da kommen manchmal ziemlich bescheuerte Sachen
raus, die keinen Sinn ergeben. Das habt ihr wahrscheinlich im Stream auch schon gemerkt.
Ich müsste noch, das würde noch nicht. Wenn ich einfach jetzt 200, 300 Millisekunden länger
darauf geguckt hätte, dann wüsste ich, was ich sagen will und es hätte keiner gemerkt. Aber nein,
ich spreche das aus, bevor ich eigentlich weiß, was ich sagen will. Oftmals fällt es nicht auf,
weil das, was ich so predikte, was ich sagen will, ist meistens das, was ich auch sagen will. Aber
manchmal wäre es sinnvoll, einfach eine halbe Sekunde länger zu warten, bevor man was sagt.
Weiß ich, ob das jemand kennt, aber das ist ziemlich dumm. Kurz was trinken.
Das ist ziemlich bescheuert, ja. Mir macht das ja Spaß. Es ist nicht so,
dass ich mir Zeit nehmen muss und sage, hier, das quält mich voll oder so. Ich habe richtig
Bock, Sonntag 9.00 Uhr zu streamen, vor allem, erstens, weil es Low IQ, Low Effort Content ist.
Ich muss ja hier gar nichts machen, großartig sonntags. Sonst muss ich mir immer, wenn wir
irgendwas programmieren oder so, muss ich mir immer Gedanken machen, was machen wir denn.
Und sonst wie, aber sonntags kann ich einfach ein bisschen schwätzen. Wir gucken uns ein paar
Videos an, ich sage was zu aktuellen Themen oder so. Ja, ja, alles gut. Man haltet es übrigens
seit Wochen, wo es kacke war, wieder besser. Ich futter jetzt einfach morgens immer so
eins, zwei Bonbons und so und dann, es bringt tatsächlich was. Rikola habe ich. Rikola
Schweizer Kräuterzucker. Wahrscheinlich grinscht jetzt der Schweizer übelst zusammen, wenn ich
das so aussprich. Ich schalte mal kurz einen. Einen Halsschieben Gachibas. So. Was gibt es
Neues? Ja, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch, Chat. Tee, Honig? Nee, ganz ehrlich, die Bonbons
sind viel, viel nicer. Ich habe mal eine Frage an die richtigen High IQ Leute im Chat und
wir wissen ja, da jeder, das ist schon wieder ein Satz, schon wieder ein Satz angefangen,
ohne zu Ende zu denken. Da jeder Prime-Sub den EQ erhöht, haben wir natürlich hier viele
absurde Five-Fat-High IQ Leute. Hat jemand von euch schon mal die Postgres Full-Text
Search verwendet? Also Full-Text-Suche mit Postgres gemacht. Ups. Kennt sich, da hat
da jemand einen Plan von? Wenn nicht, müssen wir das glaube ich mal im Stream ausprobieren,
weil, weil ich habe mir, wir machen übrigens heute Mittag wahrscheinlich mal gucken, wie
das MMO technisch aussieht, aber wahrscheinlich mal im Mittag ein bisschen Progas stream, Svelte
Skills verbessern. Aber nicht mit dem To-Do, sondern wir bauen Autocomplete für was. Und
zwar, ich habe mir auf der Arbeit ein Thema, wie nennt man das, angelacht. Kann man das,
kann man denke ich, kann man denke ich so sehen. Und zwar, habe ich meinem Chef vorgeschlagen,
dass wir das machen könnten, richtiges Hacker-Man-Thema, und hat gemeint, können wir machen und zwar
für unseren Support, der muss ab und zu mal eintragen, von wann bis wann Systeme nicht
verfügbar sind. Ihr könnt euch so vorstellen, die sitzen da vorne vor jeder Menge Monitoren
und da ploppt dann ab und zu mal ein System auf, wenn ein Checkfehl geschlagen ist und
dann müssen die gucken, ist das System wirklich down oder ist es irgendwelche anderen Probleme.
So, und manchmal kommt es ja vor, dass Systeme runtergefahren werden, absichtlich. Und dann
müssen die eintragen, System ist down, keine Ahnung, heute 23, der erste von 19 bis 20
Uhr. Und die aktuelle Lösung, die wir da gerade haben, ist ziemlich bare bones. Also,
du musst Zeit in UTC eintragen, in irgendeinem ISO Timestamp ohne Autocomplete und solche
Dinge. Und da habe ich gesagt, ich könnte ja mal einfach so eine Mini-Formular-Webseite
bauen und wir machen das selbst und machen das halt besser. Und bei der Gelegenheit habe
ich mir gedacht, wenn wir das schon besser machen, kurz die Musik ein bisschen leiser
machen, bei der Gelegenheit, ihr kennt mich ja, ich belasse es da nicht bei so einfachen
Sachen, ich muss mir dann immer richtig, richtig, ja es ist richtig Monarch-Ester-System, egal.
Also was heißt, ne, an sich ist das System eigentlich relativ gut. Die Frontend-Sachen
sind aber Müll. Und ihr kennt mich ja, wenn ich sowas baue, ich mache dann meistens immer
übertriebene Sachen. Und zwar, was ich mir überlegt habe, wäre es nicht cool, anstatt
da einfach nur einen Textwell und einen Date-Time-Picker rein zu machen, wäre es nicht cool, wenn
man die Systeme, auf die sich das bezieht, beziehungsweise auf die Alarme, auf die sich das bezieht,
doch, doch, ist es ja im Prinzip auch. Aber so einfach ist es ja nicht. Also ich dachte
mir, so wäre es nicht cool, dass man die Alarme, auf die sich das bezieht, autocompleten kann.
Also dass man eingeben kann, keine Ahnung, Hostname gleich Server-ABC oder sowas. Oder
dass man eingeben kann Server-ABC. In der vollständigen DAA meinst du vielleicht Hostname
gleich Server-ABC. So, jetzt habe ich von unserem Prometheus mal sämtliche Labels
und sämtliche Values dazu abgefragt. Das Problem ist nur, dass allein schon, jetzt
haltet euch mal fest, jetzt haltet euch wirklich mal fest, dass allein der JSON-Export, also
die rohen, unzusammenhängen und nicht großartig geordnete Daten sind 650 MB Textfile. So,
das jetzt in irgendeiner geordneten Art und Weise in Memory zu speichern, halte ich für
schwierig. Zumal man den Gramm auch noch schnell durchsuchen können muss. Also stellt euch
mal vor, ihr könnt euch einfach vorstellen, ich habe 650 MB Text und ja Stück für Stück
einlesen. Das Problem ist, ich will nicht nach 10 Sekunden was finden, ich möchte
gerne Suchzeiten haben, so am besten von einer halben Sekunde, maximal eine Sekunde, am liebsten
50, 60 Millisekunden. Also ich will autocomplete haben, wenn dann einer anfängt zu tippen
zum Beispiel, host oder so, dann soll er direkt autocompleten oder wenn einer eingibt Server
1, 2 oder wenn einer nur Server eingibt, soll er schon 10 Vorschläge erhalten, Server
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, sonst was. Das heißt, ich muss diese 650 MB JSON-Daten irgendwie
so speichern, dass ich die möglichst schnell durchsuchen kann. Die Sache ist die, ich hab's
probiert und man glaubt das gar nicht, brute force ist erstaunlich schnell. Ich hab einfach
alles eingelesen in Speicher und daraus schon den Text konstruiert, den ich dann letztendlich
ausgeben will und ich durchsuche das. Das geht verhältnismäßig schnell, aber das können
schneller gehen, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, hat jemand Ahnung von der Postgres Fulltext
Search, weil damit geht das bestimmt ähnlich schnell sagen wir mal, aber mit viel viel
weniger RAM Verbrauch. Ich mein, meine Anwendung braucht 3,5 GB RAM einfach nur, weil das ganze
Zeug den Speicher hat. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel für nix, wobei Arbeitsspeicher
ist billig. Ja, also falls jemand Ahnung hat oder hat jemand irgendwie Ahnung von euch
von irgendeiner Suchmaschine, was nicht gerade Elastic Search ist, weil Elastic Search ist
einfach mega krasser Overkill dafür. Ne, geht nicht, ich brauch alles was da drin steht,
das einzige was ich machen kann ist, und das hab ich schon gemacht, Values, die länger
als 60 Zeichen sind, die wird wahrscheinlich nie einer Autokomplizieren. Die haben schon
raus. Crab, ja mach ich ja im Prinzip grade. Im Prinzip mach ich sowas ähnliches wie Crab,
so von Hand. Vorschleife drüber, to lower, string contains, Suchbegriff. Und am Ende
noch sortieren nach dem Label. Ne, Elastic Search ist zu krass für so ein kleines Ding.
Ich mein guck mal, dann hätt ich ne Web Anwendung von, keine Ahnung, 300 Zeilen, aber ich bräuchte
den Elastic Search. Irgendwas Embeddedes wär mir natürlich lieber. Ne, aber ich mein
Postgres kanns immer einfach in nem Container starten. Man könnte auch die Fulltext Search
von SQLite verwenden, aber die ist ziemlich schlecht in Entity Framework Core integriert.
Cool Vince, Dankeschön für den Sub. Singlor auch danke für den Sub. Der Shager auch
am Start, huge Subscriptions heute, egal. Wir gucken uns das mal an, und vielleicht
mal im Mittagprogrammier streamen und basteln bisschen's Welt Autocomplete. Weil so ne Autocomplete
Form ist an sich nicht schwierig, wenn es nicht Fulltext Deutsche, äh, mal gucken, mal
gucken. Putz.js. Das hab ich mir auch überlegt. Das war das erste was ich mir überlegte,
aber nicht damit. Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich die Node.js aufm Server nehme, nen Suchindex
generiere und nen Suchindex dann kleinschicke und das rein kleinseitig mache, aber das Suchindex
ist halt dann auch irgendwie, was weiß ich, wie fett. Würde gerne alle meine Heizungen
mit neuen Thermostaten aufstellen, kannst du was empfehlen? Ja und nein. Die Frage ist
für welche Technologie? Also ich hab an meinen Heizungen, am Anfang hatte ich die hier, guckt
mal. Mal gucken, ob das die waren, aber nicht kaufen, sag ich euch gleich. Äh, äh, Moment,
da, da, da. Zigbee, Thermostat, nicht Thermostat. Ich hatte mir am Anfang mal nen 2er Pack davon,
ja, diese Dinger waren das hier, davon gekauft und Leute ich sag euch, das ist so ähnlich
sein die aus, das sind die bestimmt, die sind richtig scheiße, ich sag's, wie es ist. Richtig
scheiße, kompletter Müll. Laut, wie Sau, also richtig, wenn die, wenn die umstellen,
wenn die, wenn die, also nicht kaufen, ne? Sag ich so. Wenn die umstellen machts wirklich
bzzzzt. Ja das hat die Katze schon fast immer erschreckt, zu laut war das. Ähm, Knopf
nicht richtig zu bedienen, nicht richtig responsive, also absoluter Müll und viel, viel zu teuer.
Wir schauen mal kurz was die für Bewertung hier haben
Was haben die hier für Bewertung? Haben die? Können die überhaupt Bewertung machen? Nee, ne? Also Müll. Vor allem für den Preis
Kompletter Müll. AliExpress, sich die zu kaufen
für
Irgendwie
2,98? Das ist bestimmt AliExpress, das ist AliExpress, ich wette mit euch in Wirklichkeit sind das nur die Batterien oder irgendwie sowas
Die kosten im Leben keine 2,98
23 Euro, nice
Und was, und was, AliExpress, was genau, was genau kostet da jetzt 3 Euro? Weder das, noch das, noch das, noch das, noch das
Nichts, nicht kostet 2 Euro, 3 Euro. Was ist das denn hier? Also, ich kann schon verstehen, dass Leute lieber bei Wish bestellen als bei AliExpress
Also die Noobs, die Noobs, ja?
Die Noobs bestellen lieber bei Wish als bei AliExpress, weil Wish ist Scam, sieht aber auf den ersten Blick nicht aus wie nach Scam
AliExpress sieht aus wie Scam, ist aber meistens kein Scam. Moin
Übrigens, Leute, keine Stockfotos, legit, nur für dieses Thermostat
gefilmt
So, und, aber, ich mein, da kostet nichts 3 Euro davon
Halt, naja, Gucci Baited
So, und das hier ist halt auch letztendlich nicht mal verfügbar
Also, die Dinger sind Müll, was ich habe ist, äh, Fritz deckt Thermostat
3 Euro kostet leere Pakete, ja, die Dinger habe ich
Da würde ich aber warten, manchmal gibt es bei Amazon so ein 2er Pack Bundle, oder man muss mal bei Geizhals gucken, oder sowas
So ein 2er Pack Bundle, wo man die Dinger dann für irgendwie umgerechnet 40 Euro oder ungefähr das Stück kriegt
Die Dinger kann ich tatsächlich empfehlen, die funktionieren von allem, was ich ausprobiert habe bisher am besten
Die Batterie hält auch relativ lange, er hat mich selbst gewundert, also ich habe das eingebaut
Vorletztes Jahr, vorletztes Jahr Oktober, glaube ich, und das erste Thermostat ist jetzt auf 50%
Und das ist in dem Raum, wo im Winter wirklich auch laufend irgendwas geregelt wird, nämlich oben im Wohnzimmer
Und das finde ich ok, also ich sag mal, wenn die Batterie 2 Jahre hält, ist das in Ordnung
Wenn es nach mir geht, sollte der Gran natürlich deutlich länger halten, wie bei den Fenstersensoren, die ich habe, aber das ist ok
Nachteil bei denen ist, und warum ich jetzt nicht einfach sage, ja, kauf dir das, erstens, du brauchst eine Fritzbox, dass die Dinger funktionieren
Wobei, braucht man eine Fritzbox? Moment
Vielleicht gibt es, vielleicht gibt es ja
Irgendwas, wo das mit, na gut, du brauchst eine Deckbasis-Station, da gibt es ja im Prinzip nur, da gibt es ja im Prinzip nur sinnlicherweise die Fritzbox, die man dann auch anstellen kann
Ja, also, du brauchst eine Fritzbox, das ist das erste
Und das zweite ist, was vielleicht einigen nicht gefällt, die haben eine ziemlich lange Schaltzeit, unbekannt, danke für den Sub
Die haben eine ziemlich lange Schaltzeit
Also, die brauchen teilweise bis zu 15 Minuten, bis die schalten, die rufen nämlich nur alle 15 Minuten die Werte ab
Also, ich meine, wenn man am Gerät selber schaltet, kein Problem, dann ist es direkt, aber wenn man beispielsweise über die Heimautomatisierung setzt, dann kann es bis zu 15 Minuten dauern
Finde ich nicht schlimm, weil ich schalte einfach morgens die Dinger um 8 ein und dann gehen die halt auch ungefähr um 8 an, das reicht mir
Oder abends dann im Wohnzimmer hochgefahren und sowas, das ist okay, aber sagen wir mal, wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ah, ich gehe in 10 Minuten ins Bad und mache mich nackig
Und er drückt dann auf Heizung hochfahren und geht nach 10 Minuten ins Bad, die Heizung hat gerade ein ungünstiges Timing erwischt und fährt in 12 Minuten hoch
Ja, gut
Dafür hat man relativ lange Batterielaufzeit und ein an sich recht zuverlässig funktionierendes, rundum eigentlich gut gemachtes Gerät
Das war mir in dem Fall wichtiger
So, also die kann ich empfehlen, aber halt nur mit den Einschränkungen, die ich gerade gesagt habe
Der Konbi-Stick ist übrigens richtig nice
Ich habe übrigens gelesen, dass Sonoff jetzt auch einen ZigBee-Stick hat
Sonoff hat jetzt auch einen ZigBee-Stick glaube ich, aber, oder so, ja, keine Ahnung ob das fast taugt, aber ich habe auch einen Konbi-2 und das Ding ist richtig gut
Ich verwende aber nicht ZHA, ich verwende ZigBee to MQTT, weil es mehr Geräte unterstützt und meine besser unterstützt hat
Ja, from Colombia, nice
Kannst du mir was kleines 3D drucken und senden?
Ne
Es gibt aber Services im Internet, die machen das
Den kannst du den Sketch schicken?
Ne, ne, ne, nicht Sketch, wie heißt das?
Das STL?
Ach, keine Ahnung
Das Model, kannst du den schicken?
Oder machen die das für dich, gib 3D Drucker Services
Ansonsten wisst ihr was auch ein super Ersatz ist für kleine Plastikteile?
Heißkleber
Mach einfach Heißkleber dran
Wenn die Tastatur wackelt, mach einfach Heißkleber auf der einen Seite dran
Und im Zweifelsfall kürze es halt ein bisschen mit einer Schere bis es passt
Heißkleber ist auch ziemlich stabil
Heißkleber ist es eh unglaublich was man mit Heißkleber alles fixen kann
Unnötig, Heizung auf volle Pulle, wenn es zu warm wird, mach Fenster auf
Ja, funktioniert bei mir nicht
Weil bei mir sowohl das Thermostat als auch der Fenstersensor erkennt, dass das Fenster geöffnet wird und macht die Heizung aus
Leider, leider ist meine Heimautomatisierung zu 5-Head für diesen Vorschlag
Im Prinzip ist es so, also mit Heißkleber kann man viel machen
Ich bin selbst ja erst vor ein paar Jahren so auf Heißkleber gekommen
Ich hab mir immer gedacht, wofür brauchen die Leute Heißkleber?
Nimmst du ein bisschen Sekundenkleber, nimmst du ein bisschen Uhu oder irgendwie sowas
Aber seit ich Heißkleber hab, wird alles was zu kleben ist und das funktioniert, wird geheiß Heißklebert
Oh mein Gott, danke für den Sub
Wenn du noch einmal die Entscheidung hättest, würdest du dich beruflich umentscheiden?
Ja, würde ich
Aber ich würde es wieder genauso machen, wie vorher
Also wie ich es jetzt gemacht habe
Also wie ich das meine ist, vielleicht hab ich das noch nicht oft genug erzählt
Aber ich habe hier allen Ernstes und das kann man sich bei mir gar nicht vorstellen
Und ich mir jetzt genauso wenig, dass ich das tatsächlich mal in Erwägung gezogen habe
Ich habe tatsächlich versucht, oder was heißt versucht, ich habe, ich hab es ja nicht nur versucht
Ich hab das ja wirklich gemacht
Ich hab was Kaufmännisches gelernt
Das kann man sich bei mir nicht vorstellen
Ich hab Bürokaufbahn gelernt
Weil in einem Leben vor der IT
Und das ist so scheiße, ich hab so keinen Bock auf diesen Kram
Und ich wollte schon immer eigentlich was mit Computer machen
Um es mal so abstrakt zu sagen
Ihr kennt ja die Story, wo ich damals beim Arbeitsamt gewesen bin
Wo die mir erzählt haben, ich soll Schreiner werden, was mit Holz machen
Wo ich gesagt habe, nee nee, will ich nicht
Und ja, also das würde ich immer wieder machen
Also Kaufmännische Sachen, Bürokaufbahn, das ist überhaupt nicht meins gewesen
Ich hab ja die Ausbildung relativ spät gemacht
Ich mein, guck mal, 2007
Und ich bin 1984 geboren
Wie alt war ich da?
Kopf Quick Buffs, heute nicht, 23
Na ja, geht doch eigentlich
Geht doch eigentlich
Aber es war damals auf jeden Fall relativ spät
2007 begonnen
2007 hab ich angefangen
Also fertig war ich 2010
Mit 26
Ja, Bom Bom
Runterschlucken
Mit 26
Na ja, also die Ausbildung war nicht mit einem Haufen 16-Jähriger
Die waren auch alle 18, 19, 20
Aber ich war nicht, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
Ich war auf jeden Fall, wenn nicht der älteste, einer der zwei, drei ältesten
Auf jeden Fall
Ja
Und wie gesagt, ich hatte absolut keinen Bock auf Kaufmannskram
Das ist auch überhaupt nicht meins
Ich hab auch immer gekotzt, wenn wir in der Ausbildung, in der Berufsschule
Kaufmännische Sachen gemacht haben
Weil da musste ich mir manche Sachen
Gut, ich hatte Glück, ich hatte von vielen schon ein bisschen Ahnung
Aber das hab ich so abgefuckt, ey
Das ist überhaupt nicht meins
Ja
Heute glaub ich ein bisschen anders
Es war, also sag mal so meine Generation, vielleicht auch ein bisschen davor
Da bist du eigentlich, hast du mit 16 angefangen irgendwie deine Ausbildung zu machen
Hast du es dann ein restliches Leben gemacht
So, der Sache hab ich damals schon skeptisch gegenüber gestanden
Weil ich mir gedacht hab, ne, das mach ich bestimmt nicht
Mein letztes Mal mein ganzes Leben lang
So, zumindest, das war auch damals so, dass mir meine Eltern, die sind mir halt alle ein bisschen auf den Keks gegangen
Ich soll jetzt irgendwas machen, weil ich hab euch ja schon erzählt
Ich hab quasi nach der Schule erst mal, keine Ahnung, 2 Jahre oder so daheim gehockt
MMOs gespielt, Kreisel, Grindel und nix gemacht
Also quasi heutzutage würde man sagen Harzer Lifestyle
Aber die haben mich natürlich ziemlich genervt damals, dass ich irgendwas mache
Naja, egal
Zumindest hab ich dann irgendwann gedacht, ne, den Scheiß kannst du nicht mehr geben
Ja, klar, warum nicht
Ich denke in der heutigen Zeit ist es aber überhaupt kein Problem mehr
Wir haben einen bei uns auf der Arbeit, der ist glaub ich fast 50 mittlerweile
Und der hat seine Ausbildung auch gemacht
Fast zum gleichen Zeitpunkt wie ich
Das heißt, der war ungefähr so alt wie ich jetzt, als der seine Ausbildung gemacht hat nochmal
Also, das ist in der heutigen Zeit schon mehr drinne
Und ich sehe auch überhaupt kein Problem drinne
Wenn man älter ist und sich denkt, ey, ich hab da keinen Bock mehr drauf
Oder aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen kann ja auch sein
Es gibt nichts mehr an dem ursprünglichen Beruf oder ich will mal doch was anderes
Kann ja alles sein, ja
Sehe ich überhaupt keine Probleme drin
Und gerade Leute, die in die IT gehen, sind ja oftmals welche, die sich da schon lange dafür interessieren
Wie gesagt, ich hab Programmieren gelernt 2001
Hab ich angefangen, ich hab sogar noch ein bisschen früher angefangen mit Python, was weiß ich, 2, 1, irgendwas oder so
Uralt
Da weiß ich noch, da war ich damals noch mit meiner Mutter und ihrem Kerl im Urlaub
Das ist schon ewig her
Das muss ja irgendwie 17 oder so gewesen sein
Da hatte ich ein Python Buch dabei
So richtig Nerdstyle
Da hatte ich ein Python Buch dabei, hab das da gelesen
Offline, muss man sich vorstellen, ich hab offline Programmieren gelernt
Na ja, zumindest
Cobol, ja
Zumindest
Hat mich das damals ja alle schon interessiert
Aber zu dieser Zeit war es halt so, es gab auch nicht so viele IT-Ausbildungsplätze
Ich hab mir damals ein paar Bewerbungen geschrieben, aber das hat alles nicht funktioniert
Und ich hab mich halt belabern lassen, sowohl von meinen Eltern
Und halt auch Arbeitsamt und sonst was
Dass das halt keine so gute Idee ist, was auch immer, richtig dumm eigentlich
Und ich war halt faul as fuck
Hätte ich einfach ein paar mehr Bewerbungen geschrieben und mir ein bisschen mehr Mühe gegeben, hätte ich wahrscheinlich damals schon
Irgendeine Ausbildung in den Bereich gekriegt
Wobei man sagen muss, damals gab es glaube ich noch gar keinen Fachinformatiker
Ich glaube Fachinformatiker gibt es erst seit 2005 oder so
Na ja
Ja
Und viele Leute, die jetzt sich entscheiden in die IT zu gehen, obwohl sie vorher was anderes gemacht haben
Sind ja oftmals auch Leute, die sich dafür schon lange interessieren
Und irgendwie muss es kommen und auch schon Vorkenntnisse in dem Bereich haben
Gibt ja immer wieder hier im Stream die Frage, wie lerne ich Programmieren oder sonst was
Also ich hatte letztens einen im Stream, der meinte, er ist in irgendeinem Bootcamp gewesen oder so
Und hat das da gelernt, konnte ich überhaupt nichts zu sagen, keine Ahnung von
Also ich kenne eigentlich ausschließlich Leute, die sich das selbst beigebracht haben
Auch die, die studiert haben, die sagen alle, ja, da lernst du das
Da lernst du, was weiß ich, linked lists theoretisch, wobei linked lists eines der einfachsten Dinge ist
In der Theorie, die es so gibt, aber da gibt es natürlich ein deutlich komplizierteres
Aber so wirklich lernen tust du es nur, indem du es selbst machst und vor allem indem du liest, was andere schon fabriziert haben
Und das versuchst nachzuvollziehen
Also Code lesen und Sachen selbst programmieren und Try and Error ist eigentlich das, wie man es lernt
So, exzellent, hätten wir das
Ja, warum nicht, ich mein, wenn man auf Java, also wenn es nicht unbedingt Java sein muss, warum nicht
Ohne, ich hatte kein Notebook oder sonst was dabei, ich hatte ein Python Buch dabei offline, nur ein Buch
Das war, ich habe das heute noch, ich weiß aber nicht, wo es ist und wie es heißt
Das war ein Python lernen oder Python objekt, das war ein graues Buch
So ein komplett graues Buch
Das könnte auch, das könnte auch, Leute, ich glaube, das ist es, das war aber damals noch grau
Aber der Name kommt mir bekannt vor
Ich hab das gar nicht compile, ich hab das einfach gelesen und versteht, Mai 2005
Ich glaube aber, das war das
Das ist aber ein bisschen spät, guck mal, hier sind, hier sind Riffles von 2004
Kann das sein, dass es das einfach die letzte Ausgabe davon ist
Mit CD, jaja
Das müsste so 2001 oder so wahrscheinlich rum gewesen sein, oder 2002
Egal
Ich glaube, das war das
Gut, Turbo Pascal
Ich mein, man kann damit immer noch was machen
Aber so wirklich am Puls der Zeit würde ich nicht sagen
Eher nicht
Aber du kannst damit sicherlich noch was machen, es gibt sogar, habe ich letztens gesehen
Wie heißt das, Lazarus oder so?
Es gibt irgendwie so eine moderne Pascal Delphi Implementierung, sogar mit Gui und sowas
Ich glaube Lazarus hieß das
Wo ich mich auch gefragt habe, kennt das jemand?
Wo ich mich auch gefragt habe, all das gibt Leute, die 2022 immer noch neue Delphi und Pascal Projekte anfangen
Ich hab am, ich hab morgen, ach morgen, ich vergesse immer, morgen ist ja morgen ist ja Montag schon wieder
Gut, dass ich morgen frei hab
Und ihr nicht
Ich habe am Morgen einen Vorstellungsbericht für eine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker, ist das Datenverarbeitung?
Lazarus ist kacke, ja kann ich mir vorstellen
Habe ich nicht ausprobiert, habe ich nur letztens gelesen
Chat
Und Chat, Chat, soll ich euch nochmal mehr dran erinnern?
Okay, ich lasse es jetzt, ich lasse es jetzt sein
Ich lasse es jetzt sein
So, gleich mal 50 Leute abgeschaltet, instant
So, ja, Fachinformatiker Datenverarbeitung ist das glaube ich
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das Leute ausschreiben
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt, die gibt es ja seit 2 Jahren oder so bei der IHK
Digitale Vernetzung nicht Datenverarbeitung
Wie heißt denn das andere, wie heißt denn das andere, es gibt ja noch so ein Big Data Ding
Ich dachte das wäre das, Moment
Neue Fachinfo, es gibt doch noch so, ich dachte das ist dieses Big Data Ding
Also, zeig mal her
Daten und Prozessanalyse habe ich gemeint, nicht Datenverarbeitung
Daten und Prozessanalyse habe ich gemeint
Digitale Vernetzung
Das war früher alles Fachinformatiker Systemintegration, warum?
Egal, man muss das nicht verstehen
Aber nice
Ja, ich hoffe es klappt bei dir, der Mechaniker
Der richtige Name dafür hast du ja schon mal
Ich habe auch mit 16, 17 eine IT Ausbildung gemacht
18 angefangen zu arbeiten und mit 26 schon massiv Berufserfahrung bei uns
Fangen immer wieder Leute an mit 30, ja bei uns auch
Ja, ja, ja bei uns auch
Und man muss dazu sagen, auch ein Studium in dem Bereich garantiert dir nicht, dass du irgendwie eine super Position kriegst
Wir haben beispielsweise bei uns im Support
Ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal Support
Also dort wo Leute anrufen und sagen, oh mein System geht nicht
Und dann wird ein Ticket aufgemacht und sonst was
Da haben wir einige, die Informatik studiert haben
Aber die vielleicht den Binary Tree inverten können
Aber vor der Praxis
Nicht so viel Ahnung haben wir andere
Also es ist interessant, ja
Also Info, das heißt nicht, dass sie blöd sind oder so
Muss ich jetzt an der Stelle auch noch mal sagen, aber
Da sieht man, dass ein Informatik Studium alleine
Jetzt auch nicht Garant dafür ist, dass man irgendwie super krassen Job kriegt
Wichtig ist, dass man was kann
Und vor allem halt auch dann was, was gesucht wird
Aber wichtig ist, dass man was kann, dass man wirklich gut kann
Unsere Firma hat sowas wie Bootcamp für IT und Co.
Scrum Master, da kommen alles Mögliche rein
Auch Fischer und Physiker, um in der IT zu arbeiten
Das Ding hilft auch Fischer
Warum nicht?
Hat Unrate dich jetzt eigentlich überzeugt?
Ich habe Unrate nicht ausprobiert
Wir wollten das im Stream mal ausprobieren, haben wir doch nicht gemacht
Weil ich die letzten zwei Wochen fast nicht gestreamt habe
Guckt euch mal an, das ist ja armselig
Guckt euch mal meine Stream-Historie an
Schaut doch mal das, das ist richtig mies
Bax, Klappe halten, hier
Das ist richtig, richtig mies
Aufwachen Stream
Sieben Tage nach Voraufwachen Stream
So, und davor war Dezember
Da haben wir quasi jeden Tag gestreamt
Fast jeden Tag
Tja
Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum sich Eltern, Bekannte so in der Berufe
Naja, gut, warum sich die Eltern so einmischen, kann ich mir schon vorstellen
Die Eltern wollen halt, dass ihr Kind was macht
Und nicht daheim sitzt
Die wollen halt nicht, dass das Kind Harzer wird
Kann man sich ja auch irgendwie vorstellen
Eltern sind halt immer besorgt drum
Du warst nicht faul, sondern arbeitseffektiv
Ja, das stimmt, ja das stimmt wohl
Ich bin heute immer noch faul as fuck
Ich muss jetzt aufpassen, ab und zu guckt mein Chef auch mal ein Stream, ja
Aber ich glaube, dass es nichts Schlimmes ist, wenn man das sagt
Ich bin faul as fuck
Aber dafür sind die Sachen, behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal, ja
So aus meiner Sicht zumindest
Dafür sind die Sachen, die ich mache, insoweit durchdacht und komplett
Dass ich mich nie wieder damit beschäftigen muss
Also, faule Leute sind gar nicht mal so schlecht
Die Lösungen, die faule Leute erarbeiten, sind oftmals durchdacht
Kennt ihr dieses Chart?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das richtig hinkriege
Ich versuche es mal kurz zu malen
Das habe ich in einem Vortrag auf YouTube gesehen
Also kann sein, dass ich das jetzt nicht richtig hinbekomme
Wie macht man hier die Size von dem Stift?
So, also, so eine Tabelle
So, du hast Leute, die sind faul
Und du hast, also du hast zwei Kategorien
Faul und fleißig
Und du hast kein Plan und Ahnung
Versus Ahnung
So, also das hier ist
Wie, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Also das hier ist, das hier ist Skill
Skill
Ähm
Ich bin nicht in der Lage, das richtig, richtig zu malen, Alter
Und das hier ist, äh, ne
Das ergibt keinen Sinn, was ich da mache
Ich bin zu blöd, das aus dem Talk wiederzugeben
Zumindest war das eine, zumindest war das eine
So Entscheidungshilfe für Führungskräfte
Welche Leute sie nehmen würde
Also, also
Ich schreibe das jetzt einfach mal rein hier
Motiviert
Und, ähm, planlos gibt's die Kombination
So, dann hast du die Kombination
Motiviert
Und, ähm
Ja, wie nennen wir das andere?
Ahnung oder oder oder
Ja, wie nennt man das?
Was ist das Gegenteil von planlos?
Kompetent
Dann hast du faul
Und du hast faul
Planlos
So, das war ein Talk auf YouTube, das denke ich nicht
Das habe ich für nicht aus, das war ein Talk auf YouTube
Den ich gesehen habe, so
Und er meinte so, also so als Empfehlung für Führungskräfte
Ähm
Wo fangen wir, wo fangen wir, wo fangen wir denn an?
Faul und kompetent meinte er
Ist die optimale Führungskraft
Weil kann Leute gut delegieren
Und ist halt an qualitativ hochwertigen Lösungen interessiert
Optimale Führungskraft, faul und kompetent
Ähm
Faul und planlos ist auch nicht schlimm
Faul und planlos kannst du auch manche Leute gebrauchen
Ähm, dann gibt es noch die Kombination motiviert und kompetent
Und er meinte, also das sind so quasi die Dinger
Das sind so die Premium-Mitarbeiter, die man auf jeden Fall behalten muss
Und dann gibt es was
Das liegt relativ nah beieinander mit dem hier
Und ist auf den ersten Blick nicht richtig zu erkennen
Ähm, es gibt die Leute, die sind motiviert und planlos
Und die sind gefährlich, weil
Also wie gesagt, laut diesem YouTube-Talk
Motiviert und planlos in Kombination ist nicht etwa, dass man eine Tugend hat, aber planlos ist
Das ist das schlechteste, was es gibt, weil
Die machen laufend was, aber machen es die ganze Zeit kaputt
Die haben halt keine Ahnung und sind motiviert
Das heißt, die sind permanent am keine Ahnung machen
Das ist schlecht
Er hat gesagt, man kann alles gebrauchen, das kann man gebrauchen, das kann man gebrauchen, das kann man gebrauchen
Nur das hier, motiviert und planlos, kann man überhaupt nicht gebrauchen
Und ich finde, klingt irgendwie logisch
Genau, und ich würde mich, wenn ich jetzt mal so
Insofern selbst loben darf, ich denke nach so vielen
Streams, wo wir Sachen programmiert haben, Linux-Sachen gemacht haben, kann ich sagen
Ich hab nicht komplett keine Ahnung von diesem Bereich, ja
Also ich würde mich mal in diesem Bereich hier einordnen
Ich bin definitiv nicht hier, ich würde mich hier einordnen
Ich hab eigentlich halbwegs Ahnung von dem, was ich mache, aber ich bin faul as fuck
Motiviert und planlos gleich Azubi, wenn es ein guter, wenn es jemand ist, der sich
Gut, deswegen dürfen Azubis ja auch nichts allein machen, aber wenn es jemand ist, der wirklich motiviert ist und was lernen will
Dann ist er auch relativ schnell hier
Die Sache ist nur die, es ist durchaus möglich
Das, ach stimmt, da hab ich ganz vergessen
Das kam in dem Talk auch noch
Der hat gemeint, es kann durchaus sein, dass Leute wechseln
Also dass man viele Leute hier hat, die immer weiter auch in dieses Lager wechseln
Durch schlechtes Management
Die sind dann immer noch kompetent, aber die haben keinen Bock mehr, weil es ihnen auf den Sack geht
Zumindest das war der Talk, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Titel hieß, ich glaube, ich werde den jetzt auch nicht mehr finden
Aber ich hab so einen Talk mal geschaut auf YouTube und ich fand das eigentlich ganz gut, die Kategorisierung
Und ich glaube, die meisten kann man da wirklich einordnen
Kenne ich, kennt glaube ich jeder
Genau, deswegen würde ich mich tatsächlich da einordnen
Seit 1997 gibt es Physik, krass
Ich weiß noch, wie die vom Arbeitsamt an damals in der Schule einatmen
Jaja, haben sie bei mir auch gemacht
Okay, das haben sie bei uns nicht gemacht, aber die haben das total belacht
Es ist so lächerlich gewesen im Nachhinein, wie planlos eigentlich die Leute beim Arbeitsamt sind
Ich war ja damals auch beim Arbeitsamt
Moin Renax
Ich war ja damals auch beim Arbeitsamt und ein super Me-Advice ist auch da
Ich war ja damals auch beim Arbeitsamt und da musste ich solche, oder das sollte ich, so Zettel ausfüllen
Und da waren dann so Sachen drin, wie basteln sie gerne und sowas in der Richtung
Und das habe ich alles eingekreuzt, ja, ich bastel gerne halt, ich baue gerne Computer zusammen und sonst was
Und am Ende kommt raus, ich soll was mit Holz machen, das habe ich jetzt schon 85.000 Mal erzählt, ich weiß
Und dann hat er mir das Ergebnis gezeigt und gesagt, ich will aber nichts mit Holz machen
Ich habe das ausgefüllt, weil ich gerne mit Hardware bastel
Und da sind wir die Fragen durchgegangen und da habe ich ihm zu jeder Frage gesagt
Ja, mir geht es hier nicht um irgendwelche handwerkliche Bastelsachen
Ich will das machen, weil ich zum Beispiel Netzwerke aufbaue und so, das verstehe ich da drunter
Und da hat der Typ immer gesagt, ja, da sieht man alles auf Computer ausgelegt
So richtig überheblicher Kackspast gewesen, der Typ, Alter
Ja, ja, alles auf Computer ausgelegt, Alter
Ihr Kack-Schnarch-Nasen, Alter, das war 2000
Warte was, ich, eins oder so, keine Ahnung
Da wurden die Weichen für die Zukunft gestellt und wisst ihr was?
Wisst ihr was passiert ist? Durch so Kackspasten wie den sind wir jetzt
Also nicht durch ihn jetzt alleine, ihr wisst, wie ich das meine
Durch Kackspasten wie ihn sind wir da, wo wir heute sind
Beschissener Internetausbau, Leute, die immer noch lieber die Angst haben, bei Amazon einzukaufen
Technikfeindliche Leute, große Unternehmen, die keinen Homeoffice wollen
Wegen solchen Leuten sind wir da
Weil die 2001, da wo die Weichen mitgestellt wurden, gesagt haben, ha ha ha, was mit Computer, ha ha, jo, lun
Ja, ist so, das haben die in Japan und Korea komplett anders gemacht
Schlimm, schlimm
Richtig, genau
Was spricht gegen Java? Oracle
Nee, eigentlich spricht nichts gegen Java
Java ist durchaus in Ordnung, aber auch über, ich mach mich halt über Java ganz gerne lustig
Ich kann dazu nichts sagen
Ich hab davon keine Ahnung
Wirklich nicht, ich, ich, also ich hab mir das durchgelesen
Aber ich habe nicht gecheckt, wofür es diese drei neuen Ausbildungen jetzt eigentlich genau, genau braucht
Ich muss mal kurz mein Pulli zumachen, ja, oder meine Jacke zumachen, sonst kratzt das Mikrofon so sehr am Reißverschluss
Und dann gibt es wieder einen Clip, Max Furzt im Stream
Es gab letztens einen Clip gemacht, da bin ich hier mit dem Reißverschluss gegen das Mikrofon gekommen
Da gab es dann gleich Clip, Max Furzt im Stream
Bitkom, Bitkom sind doch immer die, die sagen Fachkräfte machen
Ja, richtig, so sieht es aus
Wie gesagt, das habe ich zwar im Video gesagt, aber das ist nicht von mir
Das ist von irgendeinem Philosoph, frag mich nicht, nicht von Schiller
Wenn man das Zitat sucht, steht oftmals, dass es von Schiller ist, ist es aber nicht, ist von irgendjemand anderem
Ich weiß nicht von wem, also das ist nicht, dass ich mir das jetzt irgendwie für das Video ausgedacht hätte
Können wollen Matrix, aha
Was für alles, ich sag doch, Prime Subs lohnen sich, wir haben so viele high IQ Leute im Chat, die sowas wissen
So, aber wir gucken uns jetzt mal Videos an, wird echt Zeit
Nee, ich hab das noch auf Papier gemacht, war noch kein Terminal
Ich bin aber letztens mal wieder bei uns in Hanau am Arbeitsamt vorbeigelaufen
Und es gibt zwei Sachen, die ich mich da gefragt habe, also an diesem Jobberatungscenter
Es gibt zwei Sachen, was ich mich da gefragt habe
Erstens, warum am Bahnhof und Umgebung eigentlich in so gut wie jeder Stadt sozialer Brennpunkt ist
Gibt es da für irgend eine Erklärung, warum ist immer Ghetto um die Bahnhöfe rum?
Was hat es mit Hauptbahnhöfen so an sich, dass da immer so sozialer Brennpunkt ist?
Keine Ahnung, bin da vorbeigelaufen, Hauptbahnhof außenrum
Und hab mir gedacht, was hier für Leute rumlaufen, fast schon wie in Frankfurt
Und genau, wie ich eigentlich drauf gekommen bin
Ich bin dann auch an diesen Beratungsräumen vorbeigelaufen vom Arbeitsamt
Da kannst du von außen reingucken
Und da scheißt da drin noch aus wie vor 15 Jahren, von den Rechnern, von dem ganzen Gebäude
Das sieht einfach aus wie technologischer Stand letztes Jahr 1000, ist es wahrscheinlich auch
Sind Hetzner-Videos schon alle vorbereitet, wo es Kubernetes gehen sollte? Nee, ich hab noch nichts weiter gemacht
Ich hab mit Hetzner auch noch nichts abgemacht für dieses Jahr
Ich müsste das an meine Managers weiterleiten
Es ist tatsächlich wirklich praktisch, wenn man so jemand hat, der das macht und der macht das auch echt gut
Ich muss gerade mal in meine Mails gucken, ich hab bestimmt wieder die Hälfte vergessen
Ich frag mich ja, wann ich die ersten Anfragen kriege, für irgendwelchen NFT-Scheiß zu promoten
Kann nicht mehr lange dauern
Wenn sogar Ozzy Osbourne einen NFT hat, das sagt schon alles
NFT of Darkness, dann keine Ahnung, wie der Kram von ihm heißt, aber dann ist vorbei
Gut, der Typ hat das ja auch nicht selbst gemacht, sondern wahrscheinlich hat ihm irgendein Berater gesagt, mach mal nen NFT
Jaja, das macht er
Also ich rede nicht von meinem Netzwerk, mein Netzwerk macht nichts
Da muss ich eh mal raus, weil die nehmen sich immer noch einen Cut von meinem YouTube-Einnahmen, ohne was zu machen dafür
Aber der Vetrus macht das echt gut
Er ist leider zu viel am Managen, dass er glaube ich so viel Zeug zu tun hat, dass er gar nicht mehr durchblickt so richtig
Oder dem sein Tag bräuchte glaube ich 38 Stunden
So, also, was gucken wir uns denn für Videos an?
Aboffers, ha, null, lustig
Ha, ha, ha, ha
KQW
Oh guck mal, ich krieg mein eigenes Video empfohlen, direkt mal draufklicken
Excellent
51.000 views, Pog
Da hat jemand eins zu eins die Nachrichten vorgelesen, stimmt überhaupt nicht
Dann zeig mir mal, was ich angeblich vorgelesen hab
Stimmt überhaupt nicht
Was machen die?
Übrigens, habt ihr schon das neueste, ähm, hast schon Poggers YouTube-Feature gesehen
Man kann jetzt hier drüber hoffern und dann geht ein Player auf
Dann können wir dem Lost zugucken, wie er sich über Battlefield auslässt
Da muss man nicht mal hier runter einen extra Tap machen
Wir können uns das tatsächlich angucken gleich
Gucken was er von sich gibt
So
Ach ja, und eine Sache, die ich vorher empfohlen bekommen habe, wo ich euch jetzt mal zeigen muss
Was mich wirklich nervt an YouTube-Thumbnails
Ist das hier
Why I stop, wir gucken uns das Video nicht an
Why I stop playing Battlefield 2042
So Leute, so sicher wie das Armen in der Kirche
Darauf, wo diese Pfeile zeigen, hat nichts damit zu tun, warum er aufhört
Und darauf, wo dieser Pfeil zeigt, hat auch nichts damit zu tun
Der ganze Screenshot, das ganze Ding hat nichts damit zu tun, weil er aufhört
Nichts
Ich hasse solche Thumbnails
Ich hasse das, das geht mir so auf den Sack
So, jetzt muss ich jetzt einfach mal los werden
Next
Kennt das noch jemand?
Ja
Warum Rot und Weiß? Wahrscheinlich, weil das dann mehr zum Klicken verleiht
Keine Ahnung
Wobei ich habe auch letztens ein Thumbnail mit Pfeilen gemacht, muss ich ja sagen
Allerdings finde ich, hat das hier
Log von J-Sicherheitslücke
Aber zumindest hat das irgendwie Bezug, weil das bin ja ich
Oh
Leute, ich muss sagen, jetzt mal ehrlich
Im Vergleich zu früher
Sind meine Thumbnails mittlerweile doch für selbst gemacht echt in Ordnung, oder?
Ich habe lange gebraucht, für dass ich überhaupt halbwegs anschaubare Thumbnails hin bekomme
Aber mittlerweile sind die doch wirklich in Ordnung
Vor allem jetzt, da ich auch die Kicks Emotes habe
Kicks NFT incoming, oh ne, bloß nicht
Ich werde nie einen NFT machen
Aber ihr wisst, wenn ich sage, ich werde nie einen NFT machen, ist das eigentlich nur Chebat, weil nächste Woche mein nächster NFT kommt
Es ist immer so, umso mehr was abgestritten wird, umso wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass es passiert
Du kriegst das kotzen, wenn du meine Thumbnails ziehst, aha, warum?
Das müssen wir jetzt etwas genauer erörtern
Alter, keiner mag meine Thumbnails, keck wait, Alter, was ist da los?
Base Reveal NFT, ja, genau
Naja, 100 Thumbnails für 10 Euro, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass da irgendwas geiles rauskommt
Zumal, da müsstest du ja im Vorfeld schon wissen, was du draufschreibst, das weiß ich ja oft mal selbst nicht
Fünf Minuten, nachdem ich das Video aufgenommen habe, immer noch nicht, also
Hast du vielleicht eine andere Vorstellung als deine User? Ja, da müsste ich erstmal wissen, was meine User für...
Ja, erzähl mal
Erzähl mal, also was würdest du oder was würdet ihr anders machen? Das ist tatsächlich kein schlechtes...
Was würdet ihr an den Thumbnails anders machen? Ich bin ja kein krasser Designer, man
Es ist echt keine schlechte Frage
Ok, das ist einfach Trollstellen, na dann
Also, was gucken wir uns jetzt für ein Video an? Achso, wir müssen uns Jibane lassen vor Level Cap, stimmt
Mehr Clickbait, ja, ich sollte unbedingt eine rote Pfeile machen
Gone wrong, gone sexual, Alter
So
Xbox making everything exclusive, mehr Buba
Ja, das ist richtig, Buba wird garantiert ziehen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass Buba zu meinem Content passt
So, also, lassen wir uns mal von Level Cap Jibane
Kurz Musik ausmachen, also Level Cap, was erzählst du uns denn?
Moment, was habe ich jetzt richtig verstanden? Ist laut genug oder soll ich noch ein bisschen lauter machen?
Ein bisschen lauter geht glaube ich noch
So
So ist gut
Hast du nur einen Bildschirm? Nee, ich habe zwei Bildschirme, ich habe links einen Chat
Und die Sachen für das Overlay und den Rest halt hier drauf
Glaubst du Dying Light 2 wird es auch so ein Release reinfallen wie gefühlt? Boah, keine Ahnung
Ich habe irgendein Anspielevent Einladung bekommen, habe ich aber
Nee, nicht nur Anspielevent, ich sollte, die haben sogar glaube ich gefragt ob ich irgendein Promotionszeug mache, habe ich aber nicht
Nicht so meins
Okay, lass uns Jibane von Level Cap
Das verstehe ich immer nicht, dass es immer so einen Fanboy Krieg ausbricht
Letztendlich ist es dumm irgendwas zu Fanboyen in dieser Richtung, weil alle daraus nur Kapital schlagen
Es wird dir niemals ein Fanboy des Monats Award verleihen
Also du wirst durch Fanboyen nie Vorteile haben
Das ist einfach so
Also es hat keinen Sinn sich jetzt irgendwie zu sagen, jawoll ich wusste schon immer
Xbox best, endlich macht Xbox, habe ich ja auch bei mir im Video gelesen, endlich macht Xbox Playstation fertig
Was ja bescheuert ist, das kann man da überhaupt nicht reinreprätieren
Letztendlich wird das nur ausgenutzt, wenn man Ultra Fanboy, also ich verstehe den Fanboy Bohr nicht
Es wird es auch nicht werden
Ja gut, Phil Spencer erzählt ja auch viel, wenn der Tag lang ist
Phil Spencer hat noch vor zwei Wochen erzählt, das hat er sich noch mit auseinandergesetzt
mit was bei Activision Blizzard gerade so abgeht, dass sie in Zukunft irgendwie nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten wollen
Gut, man könnte sagen er kauft sie, das ist keine Zusammenarbeit mehr, aber naja, die erzählen alle viel, wenn der Tag lang ist
Ist das oder Chet fragt was, das sehe ich, das hat er glaube ich recht, ist das nicht eher ein emotionales Ding, man möchte eine Beschädigung dafür haben, dass man
Ja natürlich ist es das, ist es, ist es
Das ist in vielen Bereichen so, dass selbst wenn du weißt, dass es eigentlich Blödsinn ist
Du trotzdem weiterhin darauf beharrst, weil du musst dir ja sonst eingestehen, dass du in der Vergangenheit Mist gemacht hast
Da gibt es sicherlich auch irgendein psychologisches Phänomen, Namen dafür
Ja, ist es, aber man will trotzdem, also die Realität ist halt man will trotzdem keine Vorteile davon haben
Ist es, aber ist es auf jeden Fall, stimmt es, stimmt was du sagst
Man hat mehr Spaß an der Xbox, wenn man Fanboy tut, stimmt, aktuell hat man an der Xbox sonst wenig Spaß
Im Prinzip gibt es da eigentlich keinen Unterschied mehr, Blizzard war mal ein Entwickler
Also ursprünglich gehörte Blizzard, wie war das, Vivendi, war das nicht mal Vivendi ursprünglich
Was haben die dann verkauft und dann haben die sich zusammengeschlossen zu Activision Blizzard
Blizzard an sich gibt es ja gar nicht mehr
Man könnte höchstens sagen, Blizzard ist halt der Teil von Activision Blizzard, der sich um World of Warcraft und solche Sachen kümmert
Obwohl ich mir auch da relativ sicher bin, was Anti-Cheat und sonst was angeht, ist das auch übergreifend
Hat eine smarte Steckdosenleiste, der Deal der Woche, ich weiß noch nicht mal, was das für eine Seite ist
Ricola, WLAN Steckerleiste, kann man die flashen, weiß ich nicht, die Seite sieht mit Darkstream aber ziemlich fail aus
71 Schweizer Franken, das ist ziemlich teuer, na gut es ist die Schweiz, in der Schweiz ist alles teuer, das ist saumäßig teuer das Ding
Ähm, ich hab keine Ahnung, was sind das für komische Stecker, haben die Schweizer andere Stecker oder was?
Ne, hä? Die Stecker sehen irgendwie falsch aus, was sind das für Stecker? Achso die Schweiz hat andere Stecker, Steckere
Ähm, keine Ahnung, wenn das Tuya kompatibel ist, hast du vielleicht die Chance, dass du sie flashen kannst
Aber die meiste aktuelle Firmware eher nicht, also ich würd's nicht kaufen, wenn ich nicht wüsste, dass ich flashen kann
Weil ansonsten ist es Fina Cloud Zeug
Wer hat's erfunden, genau, ok schauen wir mal weiter
Also, es ist doch ganz klar, die Sachen werden Xbox Exklusiv oder Xbox Game Pass PC wie auch immer exklusiv
Sollte sich Microsoft davon mehr Geld versprechen als sie mit dem Release auf der Playstation einnehmen
Und nachdem, zumindest was Konsolenverkäufe und sowas angeht, Playstation, ich red nicht nur von Deutschland
Generell ist der Xbox ein bisschen am Schwächeln, auch die letzten, seit der PS4, also seit der Xbox One ist es dann
Ein bisschen am Schwächeln, also sprich, sind die Verkäufe wahrscheinlich bei Sony relativ gut
Also müssten die ordentlich Kohle damit machen, dass sich das Releasing auf der Playstation nicht lohnt
Das heißt, die meisten Spiele geh ich davon aus, wenn die Cross-Platform entwickelt sind, kommen die auch auf der Playstation raus
Es hat, gut, wissen tut man es nie, es könnte immer noch sein, dass Microsoft sagt, auf geht's, kein Bock mehr
Wir machen jetzt, wir wollen jetzt unsere Sachen boosten oder so
Aber sehe ich jetzt in nächster Zeit ehrlich gesagt nicht
Umgedreht wäre es viel besser, wenn mehr Playstation Sachen auf dem PC rauskommen würden
Ich mein, God of War ist jetzt auf dem PC rausgekommen, soll wohl eine richtig gute Umsetzung sein
Hatten wir jetzt auch zwei Jahre Zeit, wann kam God of War raus? 2020 oder so?
Boy, Boy, Boy
Ach, War Thunder, wen interessiert War Thunder?
Ich würde sagen, die Kicken gehen eher raus, aber er möchte nicht, dass es so aussieht, als würde er gekickt
Aber was juckt mich, was Bobby da erzählt?
Ich mein, bei ihm wissen wir, dass er auch wirklich sehr viel erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist
Xbox really bought Activision
Allein schon das ist kompletter Blödsinn
Es ist Phil Spencer, meinetwegen Xbox
Call of Duty issued a statement on social media channels during the week announcing the postponement of Warzone and Vanguard Season 2 content
Ah, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihr Game zu verbuggt ist? Ich spiele Warzone selbst nicht mehr aktiv, ich weiß nicht, chat, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Seid ihr noch aktiv, Warzone-Spielen?
Ich spiele schon eine Weile nicht mehr aktiv, aber was ich so mitbekomme, auch von den ganzen Warzone-Content-Creators
kommt Vanguard und Kaldera nicht gut an
Zumal das Game wohl auch alle Nasen lang irgendwelche Game-Breaking-Probleme hat
Und wahrscheinlich wollen sie das jetzt erstmal ein bisschen auf Vordermann bringen, bevor die nächste Season kommt
Was wahrscheinlich auch die richtige Entscheidung ist
Ja, da sind viele nicht zufrieden mit, also bin mal gespannt, was da kommt
Siehste mal, Leute, Leute, ohne Scheiß, nochmal ein weiterer Punkt, warum Madera genau
Wisst ihr nochmal ein weiterer Punkt, warum es richtig dumm war, Battlefield 2042 rauszubringen, in dem Zustand, wie es jetzt ist
Seht euch mal vor, Battlefield 2042 würde rauskommen, in einem guten Zustand und Warzone würde gleichermaßen mit diesem Kack-Release schwächeln
Das wäre das Beste, was ihnen passieren könnte, aber verkackt
Einfach nur verkackt
Also Chat sagt, kann es sein, dass Microsoft mit dem Deal eher einen Schritt in Richtung E-Sport machen möchte
Bei der Call of Duty-Liga haben sie irgendwie keinen Plan, was sie richtig machen
Bei der Overwatch-League haben sie auch keinen Plan, was sie richtig machen
StarCraft ist E-Sport mehr oder weniger dead, die Koreaner spielen da teilweise wieder StarCraft 1
Hearthstone, Hearthstone haben wir noch
E-Sport, null, Hearthstone haben wir noch, ich weiß nicht, ob das alleine so trägt
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, das nehmen die vielleicht so mit
Und vielleicht ändern sie auch was daran, bringen das mal wieder auf Kurs, aber aktuell kannst du es knicken
Ich wüsste nicht, was man an E-Sport-Titeln von denen haben möchte
Es kann ja weder StarCraft noch Overwatch, also im aktuellen Zustand zumindest, nichts von den Blizzard-Spielen sein
Und Call of Duty kann es auch nicht sein
Die reden ja schon davon, dass Battlefield free to play werden soll
Ja, das habe ich auch gelesen und ohne Mist, ich halte diese Sache mit, Battlefield 2042 wird free to play oder kriegt einen free to play Ableger
Um die Spieler nicht zu sehr anzupissen, tatsächlich für mit die plausibelste Variante, wie man versucht das Spiel zu retten
Dafür würde auch sprechen, dass der neue Battlefield-Chef Erfahrung mit free to play-Spielen hat
Der neue Battlefield-Chef ist ja der von Apex Legends und von Titanfall
Aber hauptsächlich von Apex Legends, so von was free to play angeht, das würde passen
Ich kann es mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass free to play die wahrscheinlichste Option ist, damit irgendwie noch mal Geld zu machen
Bobby soll ja eine dicke Abfindung bekommen laut dem Fall, ja das wundert mich nicht, habe ich ja sogar in meinem Video gesagt
Egal ob der bleibt oder nicht, aber auf jeden Fall wird er nochmal dicke fetten Bonus kriegen für den Deal
Und nochmal dicke fette Abfindungen, wenn er gehen sollte, ja das wundert mich nicht
Der Typ ist ja jetzt schon nicht arm, aber dann ist er halt noch ein paar hundert Millionen reicher
Wir reden ja nicht hier, ich wollte gerade sagen, dann ist er ja ein paar Millionen reicher, nein er ist ein paar hundert Millionen reicher
Das ist ja nicht einfach so, dass wir hier von ein paar Millionen oder so, nein von 100, ich glaube der kriegt irgendwas zwischen 100 und 250 Millionen Abfindungen oder sowas
Alter, da geht es mal zur Sache
Ist überall viel Potenzial, da müssen wir bei Overwatch erstmal was drehen, dass da wieder Potenzial ist
Sorry Chat, ich habe irgendwas übersehen, irgendwelche Technik-Questions, die beantworte ich natürlich immer gerne
Wie kann ich bei Hetzner eine Subdomain machen? Brauche ich für Let's Encrypt DNS-Challenge? Traffic sagt immer Eintrag nicht gefunden
Alter
So, exellent, also was du machen kannst ist, du kannst, also es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten
Entweder nimmst du den Lordbalancer von Hetzner, der macht das alles für dich, easy, aber du musst deine Domain auf die Hetzner DNS Server umstellen, dass es funktioniert
Wenn du deine Domain auf die Hetzner DNS Server umgestellt hast, kannst du im DNS-Menü einfach eine neue Subdomain anlegen
Dann brauchst du auch keine DNS-Challenge mehr, weil du den Server exzent stehen hast und direkt drauf zugreifen kannst
Alternativ, wenn du das über API machen willst, angenehmer, dann würde ich dir tatsächlich empfehlen, nicht den Hetzner DNS zu nehmen, weil ich glaube, der Hetzner DNS
Schauen wir mal, weiß ich nicht, ob es da einen Third-Port-Plugin gibt
Da gibt es einen Third-Port-Plugin, ok, dann geht das wahrscheinlich doch damit, interessant, wusste ich nicht, dass es das gibt, das könntest du mal probieren
Aber dann würde ich was anderes nehmen, da würde ich sowas wie den Cloudflare DNS nehmen zum Beispiel, der Cloudflare DNS ist komplett kostenlos, kannst du einen Cloudflare-Account machen
Und lässt sich wunderbar über die API bedienen und hat bei allen möglichen Let's Encrypt-Libraries standardmäßig schon als Plugin mit dabei, ich meine Cloudflare ist eines der größten Anbieter, die es gibt in dem Bereich
Das ist denen doch egal, deswegen sage ich, die machen vielleicht einen Free-To-Play-Ableger, dass es nicht so offensichtlich ist, dass die Leute sich angepisst fühlen
Tja, ich würde sagen einfach einen haben, ansonsten nee, ich würde mal Berry Base gucken, aber wenn es da keinen mehr gibt, Pech gehabt erstmal, muss man wahrscheinlich abwarten
Overwatch 2 in der Versenkung verschwunden
Traffic hat Hetzner wirklich? Geil, ja, dann kannst du es da drüber machen, ja, aber du musst deine Domain auf jeden Fall so umbiegen, dass die Hetzner DNS Server verwendet werden
Also musst du die Hetzner Root Server einstellen bei deinem Domain Registrar, dass du es da drüber anlegen kannst
Ok, schauen wir jetzt erstmal fertig
Was? Sie streiken?
Es wäre ganz einfach, anstatt dass die sagen, wir delayen das, es gibt ja sicherlich was wofür die streiken, vielleicht kann man denen auch ein bisschen entgegenkommen und dann arbeiten sie wieder
Wäre ja auch möglich, ja
Ja, wie gesagt, das würde mich nicht wundern, die müssen ja irgendwas machen und wisst ihr was mich auch, neben dem was ich eben schon gesagt habe dazu, wisst ihr was mich auch stutzig macht und warum diese Free to Play Option tatsächlich was ist, was ich auch für immer wahrscheinlich erhalte
Das ist die komplette Funkstille um die Season und um wirklich substanzielle neuen Content, die halten einfach die Klappe, da kommt einfach nichts
Hätten die irgendwas in der Pipeline und würden die planen wirklich demnächst auch was zu releasen, dann hätten die schon längst riesengroße Dinger gepostet auf Twitter und würden sich drüber auslassen
Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie das so ähnlich machen wie bei Apex und da haben sie es auch mit Season Pass gemacht
Achja, wo wir gerade dabei sind, Leute, jetzt wo er das gerade zeigt, wir müssen uns zwar zwei Sachen angucken, erstens Battlefield 2042, Spielaccount, richtig nice
Also richtig, richtig nice, also von 100.000 sind noch 8.000 übrig, wohlgemerkt auf Steam, aber auf Origin und der Konsolen wird der Trend ähnlich sein und mein persönliches Highlight der Woche, die Spielerzahlen von New World
Die nicht nur zum ersten Mal deutlich unter 100.000 getroppt sind, nein, sondern quasi instant auch unter 90.000 und bald unter 80.000 droppen werden
Ja, und die bekleckern sich ja immer noch nicht mit Ruhm mit dem Game, das Game hat ja, es ist aber so, es ist bei weitem nicht in so einem ultra, na doch, eigentlich schon
Ganz ehrlich, New World und Battlefield 2042 sind zwar komplett unterschiedliche Spiele und haben eigentlich auch komplett unterschiedliche Probleme, aber die Unfähigkeit zeigt sich bei beiden
Ich mein, man muss sich mal überlegen, die haben allen Ernstes ein MMO programmiert, ich will jetzt nicht von so Sachen reden, wie dass es keinen Content gibt und sonst was
Aber habe ich mir schon oft genug zu ausgelassen, die haben ernsthaft ein MMO programmiert, wo Hit-Rack Client-Side ist
In einem MMO, Client-Side Hit-Rack, also wenn du deinen Client lext, wirst du nie getroffen und bekommst nie Damage
Warum? Warum? Wie kommt man auf die Idee, ein MMO zu entwickeln, wo die Hit-Rack Client-Side ist? Und wie kommt man auf die Idee zu sagen, ja das ist okay, das ist ein super, super Five-Hat Plan?
Keine Ahnung, ja und wie gesagt, ich habe noch nie ein, also okay, ich muss anders anfangen, MMOs haben eigentlich immer einen ziemlich holprigen Launch
Gerade am Anfang, wenn sich alles drauf stürzt und so, da sag ich gar nichts dagegen, aber New World hatte keinen holprigen Start
New World hatte den schlechtesten Start, den ich je gesehen habe in einem MMO, mir geht es nicht um Cues, mir geht es nicht um Server-Crashes, mir geht es um Sachen, die schlicht und ergreifend eines MMOs unwürdig sind
Sachen, Fehler, die sie 2020, 2021, 2022, was weiß ich, wann das Spiel tatsächlich entwickelt wurde, ist ja ewig in Entwicklung gewesen, Fehler, die Dark Age of Camelot nicht mal gemacht hat
Du konntest Items dupen, über einen Vendor, über ein Vault-System, Items dupen, das sind Sachen, die sind seit Diablo 2 eigentlich gelöste Probleme zum größten Teil
Das kommt immer mal wieder vor, aber nicht in diesem Ausmaß, du konntest Items dupen, du konntest Gold dupen, du konntest Quests, du konntest Quests, ich nenne es mal, dupen, Quests, Rewards, dupen, also XP-Rewards in New World, wirklich, es ist absolut, Cyberpunk ist ein Offline-Game
Also, die haben es geschafft, Fehler zu machen und Unfähigkeit an den Tag zu legen, in einem neuen MMO 2022 mit der Technologie von heute und der Erfahrung der letzten 20 Jahre
Dass sie Sachen verkackt haben, die EverQuest schon gut hinbekommen hat, also fehlerfrei und nicht exploitable
Ich weiß echt nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll
So, weiter
Wokehrs? Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding
Ich weiß, Leute, ich sage es jeden Stream
Aber das erste, was uns hier im Stream eingefallen ist, als sie Portal vorgestellt haben, ist Booster Server
Und dann kommt das Spiel raus und das erste, was in Portal passiert ist Booster Server
Und dann frage ich mich einfach nur, wie hinter Mond kann man bei DICE leben, dass man das nicht im Vorfeld kommen hat sehen
Es leuchtet mir einfach nicht ein
Letztendlich ist doch eh egal, das Spiel hat ja nichts zum anlocken, jeder, der das Spiel seit Release gespielt hat, eh schon alles anlockt, was er will
Es gibt nichts mehr, was man anlocken kann
Ja, sag mal so, doch, ich mache 1000 Kills mit so, meinetwegen das vielleicht, aber ansonsten ist alles da
Red Your Grave sagt, das ist ein guter Punkt, sinnbildlich für aktuelle Spiele, als ob die Leute nicht wissen, was ein gutes Spiel ausmacht, zumal sie ja schon selber gemacht haben in der Vergangenheit
Naja, ich glaube, da spielt vieles mit rein
Natürlich tragen Publisher und Hersteller und Stonks Manager und Leute, die die Spiele quasi in eine monetarisierbare Richtung drücken, erheblich dazu bei, dass Spiele in diesem Zustand oder mit diesem Gameplay und diesem Inhalt rauskommen, wie sie heutzutage machen
Aber, nur weil jemand mal ein gutes Spiel programmiert hat, und das ist, finde ich, ein Punkt, der zu selten beleuchtet wird, deswegen will ich mich da jetzt noch ein bisschen länger zu auslassen
Nur weil jemand mal ein gutes Spiel in der Richtung programmiert hat, oder auch wenn das Team mal ein gutes Spiel programmiert hat, heißt nicht automatisch, dass ihr nächstes Spiel gut werden muss
Es kommt auch ganz entscheidend darauf an, dass man einen gescheiten, wir nennen das mal Director, oder irgendwie sowas hat, ich glaube das beste aktuelle Beispiel ist Back 4 Blood
Ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig, ich war nie ein großer Left 4 Dead Spieler, aber ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig, dass Left 4 Dead eigentlich ganz gute Spiele waren, vor allem im Multiplayer richtig geklenzt haben
Back 4 Blood ist schlechter als Left 4 Dead, obwohl es mehr oder weniger das gleiche Team ist, woran liegt das? Naja, wahrscheinlich weil Valve und irgendwelche Director und Manager bei Valve die Ahnung davon hatten, was eben gemacht werden muss und was nicht das Sagen hatten
Zumindest die finalen Entscheidungen hatten, also da spielt da schon eine Rolle mit, also es war auf jeden Fall nicht nur der Entwickler, weil dann hätte ja Back 4 Blood auch wahnsinnig geil werden müssen
Ja, also da spielt mehreres rein, aber natürlich ist auf jeden Fall ein großer Punkt diese Monetarisierbarkeit von Spielen, klar, natürlich
Ja, ja das kommt ja auch noch, stimmt, das kommt ja auch noch dabei, ja da habe ich jetzt ja gar nichts dran gedacht, natürlich, das kommt ja auch noch dabei, nur weil der gleiche Name von einem Studio drauf steht oder irgendwas heißt dann gar nicht, dass es die gleichen Leute sind
Guckt mal bei Infinity Ward, Infinity Ward, wer ist denn heute aus Call of Duty 4 Zeiten noch bei Infinity Ward? Wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer
Fortnite Dance, also die schlimmste Erfahrung die ich mal hatte mit einem Fortnite Dance war am Südbahnhof irgendeine Gruppe 12-Jähriger, die allen Ernstes sich vor die Straßenbahn gestellt haben am Südbahnhof
und dort den Loser Dance gemacht haben in Richtung des Straßenbahnfahrers, das war so cringe das allein schon anzusehen, aber so ist das halt, die Fortnite Jugend von heute Leute
Ist das noch bei mir so oder hat Max wirklich ein Knistern im, oh habe ich, habe ich, Sekunde muss ich mal gucken
Ich hoffe nicht
Blablabla-Test habe ich ein Knistern im Ton wenn ich spreche blub blub blub blub blub
Blablabla-Test habe ich ein Knistern im Ton wenn ich spreche blub blub blub blub blub blub blub
Da knistert nichts
Was ist ein Loser Dance?
Ok, Leute da müsst ihr jetzt durch
Da müsst ihr jetzt durch, es gibt Leute die wissen nicht was ein Loser Dance ist
Das ist der Loser Dance
Weil er so ein L vor dem Kopf macht
Ja
Jetzt für alle die es noch nicht wussten
Jetzt wisst ihr
Was der Fortnite Loser Dance ist, ja man hätte auch darauf verzichten können aber ich dachte mit dieser Bildungslücke muss ich schließen
Fortnite Kinders in Frankfurt
So weiter, wir sind immer noch, ich habe jetzt glaube ich bei einem 9 Minuten Video 30 Minuten geschwätzt
Egal
Nein Tänze gibt es noch nicht in Battlefield 2042 aber ich denke es wird nicht mehr lange dauern
Ich meine es gibt immerhin jetzt den Weihnachtsmann Boris und den Cowboy McKay
Also da wird es wahrscheinlich zu Dances nicht mehr lange dauern
Ich wäre für den Fat Yoshi Dance
Endefft
Knallgas bringen die nicht auf Ideen
Bringen die bitte nicht auf Ideen
Ich glaube wir sind uns alle im Klaren
Das mittlerweile sobald das Wort NFT fällt
Bei den ganzen Top Manager mittlerweile die Augen auf Dollar gehen
Sag es nicht so laut
Sonst haben wir bald NFT Tänze in Battlefield
Wobei man ja sagen muss
Dass NFT Tänze genauso schwach sind wie NFT Bilder
Weil das eigentliche Talken weder was mit den Tänzen noch mit den Bildern zu tun hat
Aber ich glaube die Zusammenhängen erschließt sich nur den wenigsten
Weiß ich nicht
Auf der Arbeit haben wir IBM, nein das ist ja nicht, Lenovo sind ja Lenovo Syncpads
Aber kann ich weder großartig empfehlen noch das Gegenteil von empfehlen abraten
Wir können uns gleich mal ein Video zum Thema NFTs angucken
Ich habe ein Video irgendwo hier noch offen, der erklärt das ganz gut
Ach ja und für alle Leute die schon mal Git verwendet haben
Wusstet ihr eigentlich
Dass ihr schon ganz viele NFTs erstellt habt
Jedes Git-Commit ist quasi ein Talken
Also richtig
Also Programmierer sind hier quasi die richtigen NFT Kings schon
Shit meine ich, Shit, Shit, genau
Müsste ich echt mal machen ja
Warum nicht
Alles verkaufen
Dann hast du eine Seite, da steht hand dran
Dieses Commit gehört Easy Elite, easy easy lite
Gut das ist nicht direkt übertragbar, das stimmt schon
Gut wir schauen jetzt das Video endlich mal fertig
Ok ability
Die neue LEGO Star Wars, die Skywalker Saga, hat endlich den öffentlichen Verlust des 5. April erzielt.
Doch die neuesten Berichte über den schweren Developer-Krunch haben sicherlich eine Schande auf den neuen Gameplay-Reveal geschätzt.
Ein solcher Report hat gezeigt, dass die Game-Development von Krunch, Missmanagement und hoher Staff-Turnover enthalten hat.
Aufgrund dessen, wie auch die damaligen und aktuellen Entwickler von TT Games Studios in den UK beteiligt wurden,
hat eine Kultur, in der die Arbeit über Zeit praktisch notwendig war.
Ein Mitarbeiter hat sogar gesagt, dass das Team gesagt hat, dass es Probleme gibt, wenn die Leute nicht über Zeit arbeiten.
Mit diesen intensiven Stunden und kranken Bedingungen sind Report, dass beide TT-Game-Studios für Frauen auf ihren Teams hostile waren.
Und die Extremfälle immer wieder überall breitgetreten werden.
Und statt einfach zu antworten, bleibst du in einem Verlust, unless einer deiner Teamkameraden dich überlebt.
Wenn alle vier Spieler auf einem Team ausgeliefert sind, verlieren sie die Runde.
Der Schuss am Top ist der Ende der Runde, die Gefahr-Zone.
Diese Phase der Runde wird langsam die spielbare Bedingungen verhindern, die alle in viel stärkerer Engagement verbreiten.
Halo-Fans haben schnell um diesen Zeitraum gerettet und es sehr gut geprägt.
Es gibt immer Raum für ein Wiederholen, und die Tensionen sind hoch, während der gesamten Runde.
Dying Light 2 ist nur wenige Wochen weg vom Launchen im Februar, und die Entwickler...
Das Spiel ist doch auch schon ewig in Entwicklung, oder?
Ich kann mich... es ist doch bestimmt vier Jahre her, als ich den ersten Trailer dazugesehen habe.
...planned, haben weiter einigen wichtigen Details klargestellt, die die Fans gefragt haben.
V.a. der Upgrad-Path der Spiele. Die Spieler, die das Spiel auf PlayStation 4 ausgeliefert haben, können das Spiel auf PlayStation 5 ausgeliefert haben, ohne zusätzliche Kosten.
Das Gleiche gilt für die Xbox-Plattform, denn Dying Light 2 unterstützt auch Microsofts Smart-Delivery.
Das heißt, dass jeder, der das Spiel auf Xbox One kauft, für die Xbox-S oder Xbox-S-Version für gratis erledigt werden kann.
Die Entwickler von Dying Light 2 haben auch...
Daniel031 schwornerang schnürt jetzt ab.
...dann den Spiel postlaunchen für fünf Wochen.
Die Team sagt, dass diese fünf Wochen mit exzellenten neuen Content und Expansionen erfüllt werden.
Bevor wir auf die letzte neue Geschichte kommen, möchte ich wissen, was ihr denkt über den Activision-Blizzard-Akquisition und was es für ein paar der größten Titel der Gaming sein könnte.
...Hall of Duty.
counted as 100k mal.
Zwar nicht absolutely minibussiert, aber brauchen den sankenden Player durch das ganze
Koalitionsrevolution helllolul
...Zwar nicht absolutely minibussiert, aber brauchen den sankenden Player Clinical Pro Band.
Zwar nichtAPPX.
Marriott wie immer.
Das ist richtig, der hat das Spiel durchgespielt mit Augenbinde, oder wie?
Das ist auch scheiße, die Leute sind echt hart drauf.
Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
So, noch ein paar Questions beantworten im Chat.
Ein Grund, warum denn hier in der Gaming Industrie, ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Der Witz ist ja, Leute, die in der Gaming Industrie arbeiten, finden das bestimmt auch nicht geil.
Richtig, das könntest du machen.
Siehste, der Chat ist wieder so richtig high IQ.
Du könntest ein Git-Commit signieren, dass es von dir ist.
Und dann verkaufst du einfach deinen Private Key.
Also dann verkaufst du quasi das, womit du die Signatur erstellt hast, verkaufst du über Ebay.
Schon hast du ein Git-NFT.
Poggers.
Shit, Shit-NFTs.
Sollten wir mal machen.
Git-NFTs.
Tja, würde ich im Prinzip auch sagen, ja.
Der Sache ist halt, die Programmieren ist was Kreatives.
Oder generell ist fast alles an Spieleentwicklung kreativ.
Ja, von der Art-Abteilung bis zum Programmieren bis zum Game-Design an sich.
Und das ist halt was, wo ich mir denke, ich selbst habe noch nie ein Spiel entwickelt.
Deswegen denke ich mir das nur, dass es ähnlich ist zu anderen Software-Projekten.
Dass du Kreativität schlecht, also dass du schlecht kreative Ideen unter Druck hast.
Beziehungsweise mit jemand, der dir im Nacken sitzt.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Du kannst da bestimmt was abliefern, aber der neueste Geniestreich wird es nicht werden.
Danke für den Sub.
Ja, besteht die Chance darauf, dass Microsoft da irgendwie Entwicklung eingreift und da was umstellt.
Aber man muss halt sagen, Call of Duty verkauft sich trotzdem immer noch gut.
Und ist quasi ein sicheres, fettes Plus.
Einmal im Jahr.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Bedarf Microsoft daran sieht, da überhaupt was umzustellen.
Zumal Skill-Based Matchmaking zwar für uns der Abfuck ist.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen rein aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht wahrscheinlich die bessere Entscheidung.
Und deswegen ist es fraglich, ob Microsoft das überhaupt als Problem sieht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Versteht mich nicht falsch, ich bin absoluter Feind von Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Skill-Based Matchmaking ist eine beschissenste Sache überhaupt.
Eigentlich für alle Spieler, aber für den Hersteller ist es aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht wahrscheinlich besser, Skill-Based Matchmaking zu haben.
Die Aufsichtsbehörde, das ist richtig.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dabei.
Und der Plan ist ja eh, dass es bis 2023, wenn das alles durchgeht, läuft.
Aber ganz im Ernst, es gab ja größere Sachen schon, die aufgekauft wurden.
Oder was weiß ich, Disney hat viel aufgekauft und was, da haben die ja auch zugestimmt.
Wie letztes Jahr in einem Video gehört war, finde ich ein ganz gutes Argument.
Also, das wird wahrscheinlich durchgehen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Kreativität wird bestens mit Scrum-Arbeitsweise gehen, findest du?
Also, ich finde, wenn das richtig gemacht ist, nicht quasi zu sagen, wir machen Scrum, um es dann nicht zu machen.
Also, wisst ihr, wie ich meine, nicht einfach nur sich auf die Fahne zu schreiben und dann einfach so weiterzumachen wie immer.
Finde ich ist, sag mal so Agilität in Maßen und richtig gemacht, durchaus was Kreativität förderliches.
Weil da kannst du die Sachen selbst ein bisschen einteilen und festlegen, was du für den nächsten Sprint machen willst und sowas in der Richtung.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das prinzipiell schlecht für die Kreativität ist.
Oder aber du sagst mir, warum. Vielleicht überzeugt mich das.
Vielleicht sagst du ja aus diesen Gründen und deswegen geht das nicht. Kann ja sein.
Habe ich da noch nicht dran gedacht.
Toll of Duty hat doch jetzt auch kein Community-Management. Haben sie nicht mehr?
Früher hatten sie das immer.
Stimmt, da war doch was, ja.
Aber Microsoft kann eh alles kaufen. Microsoft hat so krass mega viel Geld.
Die machen mehr Geld als Nvidia und Netflix zusammen.
Wahrscheinlich noch mehr.
Ok, schauen wir mal. Was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Der Lockpicking Lawyer. Ok, wir gucken uns jetzt an, wie er zwei Minuten entschloss.
Einfach nur scharf anschaut und es dann automatisch aufgeht.
Halt mal her.
Lockpicking Lawyer.
Blackburn. High Level Theft Defensive.
Ein Moment. Chat. Chat. Was?
Sprint. Zumindest bei uns wird nicht von dem Team, sondern von dem Manager und Produktautern geplant.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich doof. Das ist ja gerade der Sinn.
Das ist halt, wenn man Agilität nicht richtig macht.
Das ist halt, wenn man sagt, man ist agil, aber man ist gar nicht richtig agil.
Das ist natürlich ein Projektleiter, in irgendeiner Art und Weise da Mitsprache hat,
was Features priorisiert werden müssen, was nicht, was anderes.
Aber das ist ja eines der Hauptgedanken von der, also ein Haupt, also ich habe mal dieses tatsächlich,
dieses agile Manifest nicht komplett gelesen, aber mich damit mal auseinandergesetzt.
Der hauptsächliche Punkt von dieser ganzen Agilität ist ja,
dass Entwickler und Manager sich weniger auseinandersetzen müssen miteinander.
Also dass Entwickler nicht abgefuckt werden von Managern
und Managern trotzdem noch ein bisschen, also Steuerungsmöglichkeiten auf die Projekte haben.
Das ist ja eigentlich der Kerngedanken dieser ganzen Agilitätsgeschichte.
So, wenn es natürlich, also und dass das Entwicklerteam sich halt mehr selbst organisiert.
Wenn es natürlich alles, was das ausmacht, quasi nicht gemacht wird
und trotzdem gesagt wird, wir sind super agil, dann ist es diese typische Agilität,
die wir auch bei uns auf der Arbeit haben. Wir sagen, wir sind krass modern und agil, machen es aber nicht.
Ein Beispiel, Leute, ein Beispiel von letzter Woche, wie das bei uns so ist.
Das muss ich jetzt einfach mal erzählen.
Hat jetzt nicht direkt was hier mit Scrum und sowas zu tun,
aber wir sind seit Jahren dabei, mal unsere, wie nennt man das so,
über Jahre in Zusammenarbeit entstandenen Prozesse in irgendwas Offizielles umzuwandeln.
Wir haben jede Menge ITIL-Experten und jede Menge Prozessexperten und sonst was.
Also die versuchen quasi das, was sich bei uns etabliert hat, irgendwie schriftlich mal festzuhalten
und Rahmenbedingungen, hier ist ein Scream-Bully fest, zumindest das schriftlich festzulegen.
So, das machen die Jahre bei uns schon. Das ist wirklich, die letzten drei, vier, fünf Jahre sind die da dabei.
Und letztens, okay, ich muss noch ein bisschen mehr darüber ausgehen.
Also wir haben einmal die Woche so ein Meeting, wo Wartungsarbeiten,
wo produktive Wartungsarbeiten besprochen werden.
Das nennt sich Change Advisory Board.
Das ist auch so was super agiles.
Das kennt vielleicht der eine oder andere von euch auch.
Das ist irgendwie so ein ITIL-Geschiss. So, kap.
Und da ist es wichtig und man würde davon ausgehen, dass grundlegend festge-
also, denn das erstmal grundlegend definiert ist, welche Wartungsarbeiten überhaupt
in dieses Change Advisory Board gebracht werden müssen und welche nicht.
So, und wir haben letzte Woche Wartungsarbeiten gemacht an Entwicklungssystemen.
Ich betone an Entwicklungssystemen. Also an irgendwelchen Kisten, die da stehen, dass Entwickler was testen können.
Nix, nichts live, gar nichts. Also weiter entfernt von produktiver Umgebung kannst du nicht sein.
So, und dann hat doch allen Ernstes irgendjemand in der Runde erzählt so nach dem Motto,
warum waren die Wartungsarbeiten nicht angekündigt?
Haben sie gesagt, ja, weil die nicht angekündigt werden müssen, weil das Entwicklungssysteme sind, who cares?
Und dann daraufhin haben wir den Chef vom Change Management zu einem Meeting eingeladen
und haben ihn gefragt, sag mal, welches, also ab welchem Status muss denn überhaupt
ein Change angekündigt werden in diesem Change Advisory Board?
Und dann meint er natürlich, nur für Live-Systeme, nur für produktive Systeme muss er das.
Und dann haben wir ihn gefragt, ok, kannst du uns nochmal einen Link schicken, wo das steht?
Und dann meint er, einen Staff gibt's nicht.
Das heißt, wir haben das, wir haben das grundlegendste auf der Welt nicht definiert.
Nur was es da ist und was da rein muss.
Das ist einfach nur in den Köpfen der Leute wieder drinnen.
Das ist halt, das kommt halt raus, wenn man so tun will, als macht man was, aber macht's gar nicht.
Alter.
Das ist nur wirklich das Grundlegendste überhaupt.
Viel grundlegender kann eigentlich eine Definition bei Prozessen und Abläufen nicht sein.
Also wenn man sagt, wir haben ein globales Unternehmen, zweite Meeting, wo Wartungsarbeiten vorgestellt werden müssen.
Das erste, was du definieren musst, ist, was muss da rein und was nicht?
Und das haben wir nirgends wo stehen.
Das ist der typische Fall von, wir tun so, als sind wir krass eitel und modern und sonst was, aber sind's halt nicht.
Und machen weiter wie bisher und schreien uns einfach nur auf die Fahne, wir sind's. Das ist so geil.
Au Mann.
Der Product Manager, der Scrummer, das kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Das sind auch schon Dinge, die, also fürs gleiche Projekt, das sind einfach so Sachen, die sind komplett widersprüchlich.
Ja, das haben wahrscheinlich viele.
Leute, soll ich euch mal sagen, was die beste Dokumentation ist, die ich auf der Arbeit habe,
wahrscheinlich kommt ihr drauf.
Meine Bash-History, ich hab meine Bash-History, okay, es ist eigentlich ZSH, es ist eigentlich
ZSH, aber ich sag jetzt einfach mal Bash der Einfachheit halber, ich hab meine Bash-History
schon vor Jahren auf Unlimited gestellt, ich hab eine Bash-History von, was weiß ich, 180.000
Zeilen oder so mittlerweile, meine Bash-History, irgendjemand fragt mich, kennst du Surfer
XY?
Ich drück STR, such meine Bash-History durch, ach ja, ja, kenn ich, kenn ich, kennst du,
weißt du mit welchem User man sich auf Surfer XY einloggen kann?
Sekunde, STR, Surfer, naja, weiß ich, weiß ich, der da ist es, ah logisch, ja.
Bash-History, was nicht in meiner Bash-History steht, existiert nicht, ganz einfach.
Tribullo und danke für 25 Monate Subscription, huge Sub, Hyper-Subscription, ja, ist echt
so, Bash-History, die Bash-History ist die beste Dokumentation, die ich auf der Arbeit
hab.
Ist echt so, ich hab sogar einen Backup von meiner Bash-History, ja, ich hab einen Backup,
du hast voll grad gesagt, ich hab sogar einen Backup von meiner Bash-History, Bash-History
ist das wichtigste.
Leute, ich hab bei mir mittlerweile, ich hab letztens nachgeguckt, weil das war witzig,
ich wollte auf GitHub, also ich hab einen extra, ich hab einen zweiten Account für
das GitHub der Firma und ich wollte dort mein SSH-Key hinterlegen und da hab ich mal seit
Jahren wieder in mein SSH-Key-Verzeichnis reingeguckt und mal geschaut was da drinnen
liegt.
Und gelogen, hier haben wir jetzt 16 SSH-Keys da drinnen liegen, 16 SSH-Key-Paare, IDRSA,
IDDSA, IDIDI, ich hab alles, ich hab alles liegen, 16 SSH-Key-Paare und ich hab dann
einfach random irgendeins genommen und hab's in GitHub copy-pasted, muss man ja, dass
man pushen pullen kann ohne Passwort, dann braucht man ja Key und dann sagt mir GitHub,
dieser Key ist kompromittiert, den darfst du nicht verwenden und dann hab ich nachgeguckt,
was ist denn das für ein Key und da bin ich rausgekommen, das ist noch ein Debian-Key
von 2008, kennt noch einer Debian SSH random, kennt das noch einer, get random number return
4, das war von 2008 oder sowas, also das ist ja nur ein Witz dazu, also Debian hat quasi
den random-generator gefixt, das Problem war, dass das gefixt wird und am Ende nur noch
irgendwie 60.000 verschiedene random-Nummern ausgegeben hat anstatt Milliarden und ich
hatte noch einen Key von 2008, den ich mit einem damalig verbackten Debian ausgestellt
habe, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, ich hab echt SSH-Historie der letzten, das ist
15 Jahre, achja alte Chira-Tickets suche ich auch öfters, gerade wenn irgendjemand, also
was bei uns auch oft so ist, da kommt dann irgendjemand an und sagt System XY, blablabla
soll irgendwas gemacht werden, dann denke ich mir so, hä was ist das denn, ich hab das
Gefühl des Wissen Windows, da sind wir doch überhaupt nicht für zuständig und da wird
erstmal alte Chira-Tickets durchsucht, wer damals das System für ein DNS beauftragt
hat, sag ich haha, sind wir nicht für zuständig, ja das kommt auch öfters vor bei uns, nein
das mach ich nicht, muss ich ja auch nicht, auf der Arbeit hab ich mein Notebook mit Linux
drauf, Chira, genau, so gucken wir mal weiter, gucken wir mal weiter, also ja genau, ich
muss jetzt sehen wie er das Lock aufmacht, ganz wichtig, ne der schneidet er ja nicht
durch, also ich predikte das Video mal, der nimmt einen seiner geilen Tools, wackelt dreimal
im Schloss und es ist auf, ein Hacksaw, was ist denn ein Hacksaw, das ist ne Säge mit
der man hacken kann oder, oh das ist einfach ne ganz normale Säge, ah Metallsäge, ok,
ah, jetzt hat er wieder sein speziell selbstgebautes Hacking-Dingswerkzeug am Start, 2 is binding,
click out of 4, nur ne kleiner Klick, nur ne kleiner Klick Leute, easy, easy, easy, easy,
easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, smart home tour fully automated, ok die Videos von dem guck
ich mir immer gerne an, da ist auch schon einiges an Inspiration dabei gewesen für
meine Heimautomatisierung, was ich bei ihm nicht mag ist, dass der so Alexa und Google
Fanboy ist und alles irgendwie über Voice Assistant steuert, das ist ja nix für mich,
aber gucken wir uns trotzdem mal an, jaja, was war denn da am Start, sind das Tesla Charger
oder, hat jemand ne Ahnung was das ist, was ist das irgendwelche Batterien oder, auf Zeich,
Batterien von Solar-Panels, ah verstehe, was ist das da oben, ist das ein Beamer, hat der
den, nee Liftmaster, nein das ist der Motor, ist das da oben der Motor fürs Tor, das da,
der Liftmaster, ich hab erst gesagt das ist ein Beamer, das ist der Motor, übrigens ganz
wichtig, LED-Panels in der Garage, mit einem super, oh das hat aber keinen hohen Waff Faktor,
mit diesem Schalter hier rüber aus, warum hat der überhaupt ne Steckdose da an der Decke,
richtig, richtig feifett, alter, ist sogar, ist sogar, gut bei den Amis funktioniert
das, der Board war, also Ami-Häuser, oben drüber ist wahrscheinlich das Wohnzimmer
und er bohrt einfach ein Loch durch die Decke und ist da, das ist bei uns halt ein bisschen
schwieriger, auf, wo sitzen die denn?
Ich muss sagen, ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht, natürlich kann man sich jetzt,
kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, so nach dem oder warum verbrauchte Strom, ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass der Stromverbrauch relativ gering ist in diesem Artmodus und eines, der
wirklich nicht sonderlich hübschen Sachen von Fernseher, von aktuellen Fernseher im
Zimmer ist, dass du dort halt einfach zwei Meter, so einen zwei Meter schwarzen Viereck
hast.
Ich mein, es hat schon was, oder, ist schon cool, aber wo sitzen die, ach hier, hier,
ok.
Weil eigentlich müsste ja hier ein Sofa sein, dass du da ordentlich, weil ansonsten ist
der zu weit weg, die sitzen ganz schön weit weg hier, egal, so jetzt, ja, das hab ich
bei mir auch, das hab ich bei mir auch, also ich krieg auch ne Notification, wenns klingelt,
aber mal ganz davon abgesehen, ey man hört auch wenns klingelt, hab ich gehört, also
ich habe gehört, man hört, wenns klingelt, ja beim Vorbeilaufen, beim Vorbeilaufen ist
tatsächlich cool, aber das funktioniert auch bloß bei den Amis mit einem eigenen Hof,
bei uns auf der Straße läuft laufend einer vorbei, typische Ami Kokona Schalter ist das
wieder, was du einfach so in die Wand sägen kannst, sowas würd ich bei mir nie im Leben
in die Wand bekommen, weil ich ne Wand aus Steinen hab und nicht aus Holz, manchmal
ist es tatsächlich ganz praktisch, weil dann kann man sowas da dran machen, das geht bei
mir nicht, das stimmt, ja, das stimmt, also was er uns damit sagen will und da geb ich
ihm recht ist, es ist sinnvoller ein Lichtschalter zu automatisieren als die Lampe an sich, weil
gerade Leute die technisch nicht so versiert sind, drücken lieber einen Schalter und ich
ehrlich gesagt abends wenn ich irgendwie ins Bett geh auch, die drücken lieber einen
Schalter anstatt in irgendeine App ein und auszuschalten, ja, deswegen sind so Sachen
wie die Shellys wunderbar, da hast du ein Relay, was dann letztendlich die Lampe schaltet,
das Relay kannst du über den Schalter ein und ausschalten oder über WLAN triggern,
das ist das beste aus beiden Welten finde ich, ja, aber es ist nicht die Frage mit ist
es möglich irgendwie in ein Loch in die Wand zu sägen, also in ein Loch in die Wand zu
sägen, klar ist das möglich, aber erstens ist der Aufwand ein riesen Unterschied zwischen
nimmst du eine Säge wie bei den Amis und machst das hier und saust dir die halbe Etage
damit ein und die Frage ist halt auch, willst du einfach so in eine Steinwand einen, was
ist denn das, 20 mal 20 Loch sägen oder so, schneiden oder wie auch immer man das nennt,
so ein Ding habe ich bei mir, so ein Ding habe ich beispielsweise hinter mir im Serverraum
stehen, wenn ich die Tür aufmache geht es Licht automatisch an, die sitzen ganz schön
weit weg oder, findet ihr nicht, dass es ziemlich weit weg vom Fernseher ist, vielleicht bin
ich aber einfach nur so Boomer und meine Augen sind so schlecht, ich würde wahrscheinlich
hier sitzen, dass ich wenigstens was habe davon, dass ich so einen großen Fernseher habe,
also ich habe glaube ich einen 75, wenn ich jetzt nicht Mist erzähle habe ich glaube
einen 75 Zoll Fernseher und ich sitze, wenn ich denn mal Fernseher gucke so, da, da ungefähr
würde ich sagen, von der Entfernung her, also ich bin wahrscheinlich sogar zu nah dran,
egal.
Nop, kommt mir nie ins Haus, weder Google Home noch Alexa gibt es bei mir, da bin ich
vielleicht ein bisschen Boomer, was das angeht, aber ich bin absolut kein Voice Assistant
Fan.
Ring ist auch so ein Ding, was mir nicht ins Haus kommt, ich habe da Z-Wave Sensoren,
nicht nur Z-Wave, eine Mischung habe ich, Z-Wave und ZigBee Sensoren, billiges AliExpress geht
seit Jahren ohne Batterie zu wechseln und funktioniert einfach und lässt sich besser integrieren
als das Ringzeug, Aquara habe ich auch, die Aquara Sensoren sind richtig gut, weil die
sind billig und funktionieren wunderbar, da kriegst du für 6 Euro ein Fenstersensor,
das haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Ach, der hat noch mal ein eigenes Theater, ach Moment, war das nicht so, der hat doch
letztes Jahr schon mal sein Haus gezeigt, hinter dem, wo die den Fernseher haben, hat
er die Küche, also die Kinder gucken Fernseher, während die Eltern in der Küche sind oder
irgendwie sowas, naja, das war teuer, das war bestimmt teuer, und wenn du sie diese
Dinger fertig kaufst, wenn du dir diese Dinger fertig kaufst, ist das teilweise übertrieben
teuer, also unverhältnismäßig teuer, wenn du dir mal überlegst, was die Hardware kostet,
da ist ein Microcontroller drinnen, ein paar LED-Leisten, ein paar LED Stripes und ein
Plastikgehäuse, das hat einen Materialwert von, was weiß ich, 20 Euro oder so ein Ding
und wird dann teilweise verkauft für 140 und sowas, das ist brutals teuer, das finde ich
gut, das finde ich gut, da muss ich sagen, das würde ich wahrscheinlich ähnlich machen,
Dashboards sind praktisch, es ist immer ganz praktisch, wenn du erstens die Sachen natürlich
von deinem Smartphone Tablet sonst was bedienen kannst, aber du hast ja nicht immer und überall
dein Smartphone oder dein Tablet dabei und wenn du irgendwo gerade bist und willst schnell
was machen und du hast ein Dashboard in der Nähe, ist das echt cool, deswegen, bei mir
ist es nicht so super sophistisch kältet wie bei ihm mit so einem Arm am Stuhl, ich habe
unten im Flur ein Dashboard hängen und ich habe oben im Flur ein Dashboard hängen, sieht
ein bisschen so aus wie bei ihm, plus dass ich einen Amazon Fire HD 10 verwende als Dashboard
Tablet, nicht so ein kleines Kackding.
Ich glaube, das gefällt ihm, ich glaube, das gefällt ihm richtig, wisst ihr, wie ich das
vorstelle?
Der geht dann abends mit seiner Familie rein in den Raum und die gucken fern, die Kinder
setzen sich hin und der Pfanner setzt sich dann so auf den Control-Sessel, so nach dem
Motto, ich bin hier im Chef-Sessel, ich bin am Captain-Sessel und ich mache die Steuerung,
ich glaube, das findet er cool, ist ja auch cool, so nach dem Motto, ich habe das Kommando
hier jetzt, ich mache jetzt das, ich mache jetzt das, ich drücke jetzt hier.
Und wahrscheinlich, weil die Frau sagt, ach nee, mach du das mal lieber.
Und wenn was nicht geht, wenn was nicht geht, muss er sich von seiner Frau wahrscheinlich
anhören, ja, warum muss das auch so kompliziert sein, hättest du nicht einfach einen Knopf
hin machen können oder sowas?
Kann ich mir richtig vorstellen, also wenn ich sein Haus richtig in Erinnerung habe,
ist die Kitchen direkt hinter dem, was wir eben mit dem Fernseher gesehen haben.
Alter, das ist ja ein riesen Motion-Sensor, sick Motion-Sensor, die gibt's, die gibt's
schon, die sind nur so, aha, okay, das finde ich praktisch, okay, das finde ich praktisch,
okay, das finde ich praktisch, okay, das finde ich praktisch, okay, das finde ich praktisch,
Dashboard
Ach nee, das ist ein Echo Dashboard
Ein Echo-Dings, nee nee nee, gehen wir mal fort
Kommt bei mir auch nicht ins Haus. Alles mit irgendwelchen komischen Cloud-Services oder so will ich nicht haben
Ich frage mich, wie es bei ihm im Haus aussieht, wenn sein Internet mal nicht funktioniert
Ich meine ich brauch doch kein Cloud-Service für irgendwie einen Thermostat, jetzt mal ernsthaft, man kann es auch übertreiben
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern? Vor zwei Jahren oder so, als AWS mal down war, als AWS Probleme hatte, wo die Leute ihre Heizung nicht richtig einschalten konnten
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, null, Alter, warum macht man sowas über den Cloud-Service?
Man, man, man, warum kann man die iPads nicht einfach da oben drauf legen?
Also, warum, warum müssen die in der Box, also, warum? Verstehe ich nicht, aber okay
Warum legt man die nicht einfach da oben drauf? Reduziert Wischl-Klatter, ah ja
Ah, das ist, das kenne ich, das ist, wo du tracken kannst, wo die Leute gerade im Haus sind
Da musst du aber dein Handy dabei haben und sowas
Das habe ich mir auch mal überlegt, das funktioniert bei mir aber nur zum Teil, weil ich mein Handy oftmals halt nicht mitnehme
Also ich nehme mein Handy eigentlich nie mit, außer ich verlasse das Haus oder ich gehe aufs Klo
Weil auf dem Klo brauche ich irgendwas wo ich lesen kann, aber ansonsten liegt das eigentlich immer hier neben mir auf dem Schreibtisch
Wenn ich runter in die Küche gehe, mir was zu trinken holen, nehme ich das Handy nicht mit
Wofür brauchen die Kids nun die Tablets, ja wahrscheinlich um Microtransactions Geld auszugeben?
Das weiß ich, was Kinder das halt so an Tablets eben machen
Keine smarte Abstellkammer, weird champ
Ja die habe ich auch, ne die habe ich nicht, ich habe kein UniFi 6
Was kosten die Dinger eigentlich mittlerweile, ich habe drei, ich habe drei nicht Wi-Fi 6
Wobei ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher, Sekunde Leute ich muss mal kurz auf meinem Handy gucken, was ich für welche habe
Zack, vielleicht sind die nämlich auch schon, Wi-Fi 6
Oh anstrengende Musik, Zack Amazon, Amazon History kurz kurz checken, Amazon, Amazon History
Leute ich habe auch wieder so ein komisches Ding auf meinem iPhone, einmal am Tag kriege ich jetzt neuerdings Siri Suggestions
Also Siri Empfehlung und einmal am Tag sagt mir Siri, Suggestion, Amazon Orders
Die empfehlt mir quasi einmal am Tag in meine Amazon Orders zu gucken, aber ich habe überhaupt nichts geordert
Siri ist ziemlich low IQ gerade, ich weiß gar nicht warum ich den Mist überhaupt an habe auf dem iPhone
UniFi Nano HD, der hat kein Wi-Fi 6, der Nano HD
UniFi Lite, den habe ich, das ist auch kein Wi-Fi 6
Boah muss ich, muss ich demnächst upgraden UniFi 6
Musik
Mal ganz davon abgesehen ist es ja nicht, ist kein Vorteil für mich so wirklich
Also ich mein warum sollte ich upgraden meine 3 Access Points jetzt auf Wi-Fi 6 Access Points weil alles funktioniert
Wozu, ne ist ja nicht so als werde ich jetzt irgendwie Hilfe mein WLAN ist morgen kaputt wenn ich nicht upgrade
Was ist der Vorteil, jetzt mal, vielleicht hat da einer von euch Plan, UniFi 6 vs Nano HD
So
Genau was ist da der Vorteil von
Ja gut 300 MBit über Wi-Fi ist jetzt nicht so als wäre es für wenig
Musik
Weil du keine Wi-Fi 6 Endgeräte hast, ich habe ein iPhone 11, kann das iPhone 11 Wi-Fi 6
Oder nicht
Doch anscheinend, anscheinend
Man kann das aber doch auch bestimmt mischen oder, also ich könnte doch, ich könnte doch im Keller den alten AC Lite lassen
Und den Nano HD austauschen durch den Wi-Fi 6, also ich muss das doch bestimmt nicht alles austauschen, wozu
Bei dem Keller für die drei Geräte die da stehen reicht der normale AC Lite ja easy aus
Hier, okay das gucke ich mir nachher an, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht zusammen an
Rüber, rüber, excellent, excellent, so weiter gehts
Video, wo sind wir schon stehen geblieben hier, keine Smart Abstellkammer
Wie funktioniert das eigentlich, das ist eine gute Frage sag ich jetzt kurz mal so
Wie funktioniert das eigentlich mit deinem China WLAN, braucht man dann bessere Access Point mit mehr Antennen dafür, nein
Braucht man nicht, du kannst mehrere SSIDs broadcasten, meistens, ich glaube bei UniFi sind es vier pro Access Point
Du kannst mit einem Access Point mehrere SSIDs broadcasten und du brauchst halt einen Access Point der WLAN
Einstellungen hat, also der WLAN Unterstützung hat, was eigentlich so gut wie alle etwas besseren sind
Und natürlich halt auch dementsprechenden Switch auf der anderen Seite, der das kann
Mehrere Antennen braucht er nicht, das ist eine 2,4 Gigahertz Antenne oder eine 5 Gigahertz Antenne
Da kannst du mehrere SSIDs drüber machen, das ist kein Problem
Die sich dann eigentlich und schaltet das Wifi 6 der Autobahn Wifi, nee ich glaube nicht
Ich bin kein großer Wifi Kenner, aber das glaube ich nicht, also ich hab es bei mir so eingestellt
Das Default WLAN, halt das normale WLAN, ich benutze das Default WLAN und das China, China Chinesen Geräte WLAN hat ein eigenes
Ah guck mal Katzenklappe, ah nee eine Hundeklappe
Oh, Big Brain Idee, Pfeifett-Time
Das ist schlau, das ist richtig schlau, weil ich hab mir auch schonmal überlegt für die Katzenklappe unten
Chico benutzt ja die Katzenklappe nicht, aber ich hab mir überlegt ob ich die im Sommer fülle, egal
Gucken wir mal, ich wollte es nämlich im Sommer so machen, dass Chico raus auf die Terrasse kann
Nicht komplett in Hof und auch nicht irgendwie über die Mauer oder so, aber auch rauf auf die Terrasse
Und ich hab mir schon Gedanken gemacht, wie könnte ich mitbekommen ob die Katze draußen ist oder drinnen ist
Meine erste Idee war, ich mach an die Klappe ein Fenstersensor, der das erkennt, aber das kann man nicht richtig anbringen
Weil die Klappe die fällt ja hier rein, du kannst wirklich schlecht einen Sensor anbringen
Du könntest höchstens einen Sensor hier oben anbringen, wenn es kurz auf ist, also das ist nicht so zuverlässig
Aber das finde ich ist eine super Idee, das muss ich mir aufschreiben, Motion Sensor in die Katzenklappe
Sehr gute Idee, richtig clever
Und das gute ist, wir haben sogar einen Stromanschluss direkt daneben, vielleicht kann ich sogar den Kram an USB anschließen
So ein dünnes USB-Kabel nehmen und irgendwie mal gucken, mal gucken, das ist gut, das ist eine wirklich schlaue Idee, das gefällt mir
Das gefällt mir, das ist eine gute Idee
Meine Katze ist gechipt, aber dann bräuchtest du halt irgendwas, was das liest, da musst du dann davor sein und so
Weiß ich nicht, ob das so gut funktioniert
Kennst du da irgendwelche guten Reader für?
Der RFID-Reader sind winkelabhängig und müssen halt relativ nahe sein
Je nachdem wie die da durchläuft
Ne, unbefugte Katzen draußen bleiben geht nicht, die unbefugte Katzen kommen ja gar nicht rein, wie gesagt die Terrasse ist ja abgeschlossen, also nicht abgeschlossen
Die ist geschlossen, also du kommst ja von der Terrasse nicht von außen rein und die Katze nicht raus
Da würde ich Chico schocken mit
Was ist das?
Is das Wäsche?
Das ist Wäsche glaube ich
Ok Leute, ich glaube das ist eines der sinnlosen Gadgets wo du Geld für ausgeben kannst
Bei einem smarten Geschirrspüler oder Wäsche trocknen oder sowas
Weil festzustellen wann der fertig getrocknet hat ist glaube ich der eines der einfachsten
Kurz die Musiklautstärke checken
Eines der einfachsten Dinger überhaupt
Man kann einfach eine Steckdose dran machen, die guckt wie viel Strom das Ding verbraucht
Sagen wir mal über 5 Minuten lang unter einem gewissen Wert ist, dann weißt du es ist fertig
Und wenn du richtig advanced sein willst kannst du da auch noch ein Rüttelsensor dran machen
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich alles besser und deutlich billiger funktionieren als irgendwelche smarten Wäschetrockner
Also vor allem billiger
Wenn die Waschmaschine beginnt wird es ein Smart Switch geben, welches einen Exhaust-Fan in der Klappe kontrolliert
Weil wir hier viele andere Produkte in der Klappe haben und wir wollen sie nicht zu dünn werden wenn die Waschmaschine und der Dreier geht
Es geht viel mit diesem Server-Rack, alle Ethernet Kabel aus unserem Haus kommen zu diesem einen Punkt
Eigentlich eine gute Stelle, ganz ehrlich, im Wäscheraum, warum nicht, wenn da Platz ist, meine Beluchtfeuchtigkeit je nachdem wie hoch sie da ist, könnte man sich vielleicht nur streiten, aber das macht meistens nichts
Es ist eigentlich ein guter Platz, es liegt wahrscheinlich relativ zentral, es wird kaum benutzt und wenn ist da eh Krach drin, eigentlich ist es, wenn da Platz ist, ist es eigentlich ein super Ort
Als Mini-Rack-Server-Raum, dort wo die Wäsche ist, warum nicht
Wir haben einen Ethernet-Kabel oder einen Port in fast jedem Zimmer, sowie POE-Kameras aus unserem Haus
Und all diese Kameras, z.B. unsere Doorbell, die Wi-Fi, verbinden mit diesem Unified Dream Machine Pro
Und das ist ein Hard-Rider-Fan und kann 24-7 Fotos machen
Es gibt auch ein paar Vakuen hier, die Dyson V10 Animal Plus, die wir gerade auf Black Friday gekauft haben
Der Name von dem Staubsauger, Alter
Dyson Cyclone V10 Animal Plus, alles klar
Aber wahrscheinlich Animal, weil der für Haustierhaare ist, hä?
Sink-Sinai-Bits, Gachi-Buzz
Ja, das hatte ich auch so
Das hatte ich auch so
Aber ich hab's letzten Sonntag ja schon erzählt
Ich verwende aktuell meinen Staubsauger-Roboter nicht mehr, sondern ich fahre da alle paar Wochen mal 10 Minuten lang mit dem richtigen Staubsauger durch und gut ist
Nein, das mag ich nicht
Ich sehe es nicht ein, ich will keinen Roboter haben mit Kameras vorne, der vor allem dann auch noch über die China-Chinesen-Cloud geht
Ich mag die Dream Machines auch nicht, ich kann die gar nicht so genau sagen warum
Aber jedes Mal wenn ich mir das durchgelesen hab, gerade auch das Webinterface, wo du dann nicht so sehr ins Detail kannst, hat mich nicht so überzeugt
Dyson ist echt Müll, ist das so? Weiß nicht, kann ich nix zu sagen
Makes no sense, Dota 16 Monate, danke schön für den Sub
Ich verwende ihn nicht mehr, weil es schneller ist 10 Minuten lang einfach mal mit dem richtigen Staubsauger durch zu flitzen
Gibt es OpenWRT oder sowas vor Dream Machine?
Wobei es heißt doch nicht mehr OpenWRT, es heißt Lede oder?
Lede? Wie heißt denn der Kram jetzt? Lede heißt es doch jetzt oder?
OpenWRT, Dream Machine, gibt es das?
Das wäre schon besser zu benutzen
Wir benutzen auch die brillanten Lichtschuhe, um schnell auch unsere Smart Home zu verändern
Es gibt auch Z-Wave und ZigBee Extender hier, weil es das Mitte unserer Hause ist
Und der ZigBee Extender ist einfach nur ein Smart Outlet, der nicht zu was verbunden ist, das funktioniert sehr gut
Das ist kein ZigBee Extender, so ist ZigBee gedacht, ZigBee ist als Mesh gedacht, genauso wie Z-Wave
Alle Geräte, die du in die Steckdose steckst oder alle Geräte, die permanent am Strom sind, fungieren quasi als Extender, Repeater, wie auch immer
Also sind quasi zu einem festen Mesh-Node, der die Sachen weiterleitet
Das ist der Sinn von ZigBee und Z-Wave, deswegen ist die Abdeckung und die Reichweite davon auch so gut
Was ist daran Smart?
Ich meine, er dreht da dran oder dreht sich das automatisch?
Dreht er da jetzt dran oder ist es ein Motor, der automatisch dreht? Also wenn es ein Motor ist, dann ist es natürlich 5-Fett-Lösung
Aber gut, da muss ja ein Anschluss, da muss eine Steckdose in der Nähe sein
Das ist auch so was, wo ich mich noch nicht dazu durchgerungen habe, ich habe mir einmal testweise einen automatischen Rolladen-Wickler gekauft, weil ich habe ja noch mindestens 4 Räume mit so einem klassischen Holz-Rolladen
Einen richtig fetten schweren Ding, habe ich mich aber noch nicht dazu durchgerungen, das zu machen, weil ganz im Ernst morgens schnell hochziehen und meistens lasse ich ihn sogar abends auf, weil ich zu faul bin
Aber morgens, wenn es doch zu ist, mal schnell hochziehen, ist kein Ding
Ich finde, man muss es an den Stellen machen, wo es Sinn macht und an den Stellen, wo es einen nervt
Gerade dort ist Heimautomatisierung sinnvoll, wenn es am Arbeit abnimmt, die nervt
Und dementsprechend ist es auch immer was Individuelles, ich sehe total viele Leute, die fangen an mit RGB-LEDs durchs ganze Haus
90% der Stellen braucht man überhaupt keine RGB-LEDs, man braucht vielleicht was Dimmbares, aber keine RGB-LEDs
Und dann denken sie sich, was kann ich denn jetzt machen, also das finde ich der falsche Ansatz, man muss sich überlegen, was einen stört
Und das dann umbauen und nicht umgedreht, nur weil man coole Youtube-Videos gesehen hat, die alle RGBs haben oder irgendwelche Sensoren oder sonst was, die auch einbauen, wenn das eigentlich nichts ist, was einen stört
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine, also man muss direkt den Mehrwert dafür schaffen und gerade wenn man nicht alleine ist, ist es besonders wichtig, dass halt auch die anderen Personen, die das benutzen müssen, erstens gut benutzen können und zweitens den Mehrwert davon sehen
Deswegen war das erste, was ich damals auch gemacht habe, ist eine, tatsächlich eine RGB-LED, die per Farbe anzeigt, wenn ich morgens aus dem Schlafzimmer komme, anzeigt, ob man Zugverspätung hat oder nicht
Ich hab die Tür aufgemacht, hab gleich gesehen, oh nee, rot
Das war tatsächlich Mehrwert, das hat tatsächlich was gebracht
Hab ich aber übrigens mittlerweile nicht mehr
Was da, der ist in Rauch aufgegangen? Oh, das ist schlecht
Gerade, weil man die Dinger ja auch einstellt auf automatisch, man stellt ja so einen Rolladenwickler ein, keine Ahnung, geh morgens um 8 automatisch auf, geh bei Sonnenuntergang automatisch zu und sowas
Das heißt, die Dinger Rolladen wickeln auch wenn man nicht daheim ist
Wenn das anfängt zu rauchen und anfängt zu brennen und man ist nicht da, dann ist das gefährlich
Willst du verraten, was das für einer war? Ich hab einen von, ich hab einen Duo, nee wie heißt dieses Ding?
Oh, ich hab vergessen, Duo Gurt oder sowas, Moment, Moment, Rolladenwickler Duo
Duo Fern, ich glaub davon hab ich mir mal einen geholt, als der im Angebot war für irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 60 Euro oder so, 180, die sind eigentlich gestört
Und hab mir den offiziellen USB Stick von denen geholt, weil ich das damit automatisieren wollte, hab ich aber nie gemacht
Trinity, danke für den Sub
Die Oberfläche von der Dream Machine sagt, der Chat wird mit jedem Update schlechter
Äh, kann ich, zur Dream Machine kann ich nichts sagen, aber ich muss sagen, ich bin mit dem Unify Update auch nicht so wirklich glücklich
Das neue sieht zwar schöner aus, aber die haben einige Funktionen gestrichen
Ich hab instant wieder zurück auf die alte, auf die alte Oberfläche für Unify geschaltet
Vor allem finde ich da wenigstens was
Rademacher hab ich auch, ja, genau, die hab ich auch
Die hab ich auch gehabt, ja, zum Testen
Oh, wenn der anfängt zu rauchen, ist aber echt schlecht
Das war aktuell, das hat die deutsche Bahnintegration von Home Assistant verwendet
DNS Challenge failed, was ist los Chat?
Warum failed eure DNS Challenge? DNS Challenge failed, failed to find zone
Ähm, wenn du DNS Challenge machst, muss der Traffic AP Zugang zum DNS Server haben, ne?
Der muss da einen geheimen Key hinterlegen, hat dein Traffic AP Access auf deinem DNS
Und ist dein DNS auch beim Domain Regulierung, oder?
Und ist dein DNS auch beim Domain Registrar eingestellt
Sonst funktioniert das nicht
Aber du musst keine DNS Challenge machen, wenn das Ding eh im Internet steht, kannst du auch normale HTTP Challenge machen
Dann brauchst du nur einen Eintrag und gut ist
SOMPHY
SOMPHY haben wir auch, was geht mit der Musik, aber das ist grad viel zu epische Geschichte hier
SOMPHY haben wir auch bei den anderen Fenstern, die nicht mehr diese oldschool fetten Rollern, Holzrollen haben
Die haben auch schon einen Motor, das ist relativ easy
Und die kann ich auch fernsteuern, noch richtig oldschool über Funk, also RF 433 oder was das ist
Das funktioniert, die kann ich steuern
Bad oben, bad unten, Küche unten, kein Ding
Ne, oder ist doof, ich hab mir damals noch einen gekauft, ich hab den auch hier
SOMPHY
Pain in the ass, sketchybuzz
Danke für den Sub, Leute, Luxius, Slimy und Flofus
Tja, dann würde ich mal die DNS Management Konsole aus das Webinterface aufmachen, während dein Traffic läuft und gucken
Ob dein Traffic dort Sachen anlegt, da müssten ja dann TXT Records auftauchen
Wenn da keine TXT Records auftauchen, dann scheint es nicht zu funktionieren
Ok, die Weboberfläche, es sagt
Unterschied zwischen Paravirtualisierung M und VMM
Was, was ist VMM, was ist VMM, Leute
Ich bin, ich bin low IQ, was, was ist VMM
Virtual Machine Monitor, hä?
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Eine Frage, ich will, wenn mein PC ausgeschaltet ist, automatisch meine Steckdosen vom PC ausschalten, nachdem dreimal der Pin gefällt
Es gibt, ja easy, kannst du mit Home Assistant easy machen, easy
Überhaupt gar kein Problem
Kannst du machen
Ist sogar eine richtig gute Idee, finde ich
Kannst du easy machen
Home Assistant, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es da einen ICMP oder sowas gibt
Ja, gibt es
ICMP Sensor kannst du machen
ICMP Sensor und dann sagst du hier
Wenn der, wenn der auf off geht oder wenn der auf failed geht, dann schaltest du nach 5 Minuten aus
Ich würde das gar nicht nach 3 failed pings machen, ich würde das
Ich würde sagen, wenn der Sensor für 10 Minuten auf aus steht, dann macht die Steckdose aus
Das ist mit Home Assistant easy, das ist 3 Zeilen Automatisierung
Okay, was, wir müssen uns die Smart Home Tour noch fertig angucken
Ich finde diese Kokona Switch so reingeschnitten in die Wand immer so geil
Moment, muss ich auch kurz was zu sagen, hier geht ja wieder Schlag auf Schlag im Chat
Noch so ein Ding, Home Assistant auf dem Pi direkt drauf oder in Docker Container, irgendwas war doch kacke
Ja, du kannst das nicht mehr richtig machen mit selbst Docker Container, wenn du Home Assistant verwenden willst
Das ist keine supportete, also diese Home Assistant super weiß, ist keine richtige supportete Konfiguration mehr
Da spackt das Ding rum
Die beste Variante, wenn du es auf dem Raspberry Pi machen willst, ist tatsächlich das direkt auf dem Raspberry Pi installieren
Aber, aber, machs mit SSD
Neben den USB zu SSD und papp dir mit Parthesa Power Strips oder mit Velcro Dingern oder was auch immer
Papp dir eine SSD unter den Raspberry Pi
Also, du hast ja ein Raspberry Pi Gehäuse, papp dir eine SSD drunter und mach das darauf, weil Home Assistant ist abfach langsam über Micro SD
Also, wenn du es mit dem Raspberry Pi machen willst, dann würde ich einen kompletten Raspberry Pi für Home Assistant opfern
Ja, das würde ich machen
Ich habe es bei mir anders, ich habe eine VM auf meiner Low Power Intel x86 Hardware, eine VM mit Home Assistant, die tut auch wunderbar
Das wird dauern, wenn überhaupt
Das ist auch eine gute Idee, man kann den BIOS einstellen, sobald der Strom wieder da ist, geht er an, dann kannst du auch wieder darüber
Der Pi, jaja klar
Aber nur über Micro SD ist langsam, ein Raspberry Pi 3 hat auch genug Leistung
Du brauchst auch keine 8 GB RAM, 4 reichen
Den Friedhof Sensor, der ist nicht im Einsatz
Den habe ich ja nie fertig gebaut, aber ist immer noch in Planung
Was nimmst du als Hypervisor? Ich habe ganz normales KVM
KVM Wirtmanager, die easiest Sache überhaupt, die man unter Linux machen kann
Kriste angelegt, Home Assistant drauf, fertig
Ja, wir haben, ich habe mit LoRa, über LoRa war einmal ein Sensor programmiert mit Bodenfeuchtigkeit
Das war ein ESP32 mit Batterie und Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor und einem LoRa Sender
Und ich wollte das auf den Friedhof bringen, der ist irgendwie 1,5 Kilometer weg von hier
Auf den Friedhof bringen, wo das Grab von Opa und Oma ist
Und wollte das quasi dort den Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor dort reinstecken, dass der mir heimschickt über LoRa
Das hat übrigens auch funktioniert, das habe ich ausprobiert, von der Entfernung her ging das
Im allerniedrigsten Übertragungsmodus, dass der mir heimschickt, wie feucht oder trocken das Grab im Sommer ist
Dass ich weiß, wann ich gießen gehen muss
Smart Grave
Ne, weiß ich nicht, kann ich dir nichts empfehlen
So, wir gucken jetzt aber echt mal das Video fertig, es wird immer langsam Zeit
Wir haben wieder drei Videos heute geschafft
Hier auch
Und mein Lieblingsgebiet ist die Lichter, die automatisch aufstehen
Garage?
Ist es Garage oder Garage? Ich kann mir das wahrscheinlich dahin achten, wo man herkommt
Ihr seht, es ist hier wirklich lecker
Und es gibt ein schönes weißes Licht
Und es liegt auf dem ganzen Garage und macht es fühlen, als würde man hier hängen und arbeiten
Und es ist automatisch mit einem Smart-Outlet
Es ist direkt oben auf dem Böschel
Also, wenn irgendeine der Garage-Dörche öffnen, werden all diese Lichter geöffnet
Das sieht wirklich toll aus
Und hier, in diesem Garage, ist immer noch ein Schritt in der Arbeit
Aber wir haben einen Echo-Dock
Natürlich, was sonst? Warum hat da überall jedenfalls die Echos rumstehen?
FBI-Open-Up
Wir haben auch drei Tesla-Power-Wall
Und diese Sachen sind toll, weil sie unsere ganze Haus- und sogar unsere zwei AC-Unit aufbauen können, wenn die Grit unten ist
Und wir benutzen diese mit unseren Tesla-Solar-Paneln auf unserem Ruf
Und wir haben ein ganzes Video auf den Tesla-Power-Wallen
Gut, der ist ja auch irgendwo mitten in der Wüste oder so
Ich weiß nicht mal, wo er wohnt, aber das war wirklich was mit irgendwie Gefühl, jeden Tag 30 Stunden Sonne
Was schwierig wird jeden Tag
Boah, das wäre mir viel zu krass, wenn ich jetzt...
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, ich gehe nachts mal aufs Klo und das erste, was ist, ist so ein LED-Licht, was mir von der Decke ins Gesicht scheint
Ja, super
Also, das ist ja ein bisschen...
Das ist ein bisschen...
啦
Lash
Ich habe gerade gedacht, er hatte LED's drumrum aber es ist Licht von außen
Was cool ist, diese Lichter, die von Lutron kontrolliert werden,
und diese Lutron-Schäden haben diese kleinen Pico-Remotes,
und die kannst du irgendwo hinlegen
und die kannst du einfach irgendwo in deinem Zimmer kontrollieren.
Also haben wir einige in meiner Frau's Nachtstand,
und so kann sie die Lichter und die Schäden sehr einfach kontrollieren.
Wir haben auch eine montierte TV, die etwas weit von unserem Bett ist,
also benutzen wir die Echo-Dots auf unserer Nachtstand,
und so können wir die Lichter und die Schäden sehr einfach kontrollieren.
... als Spiegel für die TV.
So müssen wir nicht den Sound über das Zimmer blasen,
und wir müssen alle in der Nacht in die Haus-Stand arbeiten.
Und bevor du denkst, wow, du hast Echo-Dots im Zimmer,
keine Sorge, wir haben auch ein Google-Haus-Display.
Also benutze ich das Google-Display, um alles zu kontrollieren.
... im Leben nicht.
So was nicht nur im Bedroom, überhaupt nicht.
... mit einem Schlafsensor unter dem Bett.
Oh, das ist eine gute Idee, wenn es sowas ist,
was per Druck feststellt, ob jemand drinnen liegt im Bett.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Das finde ich tatsächlich ganz cool, sowas kann man machen.
Ich habe es aktuell mit einem NFC-Tag.
Einfach Handy dranhalten und easy, wir gehen ins Bett.
Aber man kann es auch komplett automatisch machen,
dass das alles ausschaltet, was noch an ist,
wenn man keine Ahnung, eine Viertelstunde im Bett liegt
und es nach 22 Uhr ist.
Das finde ich ist eine gute Idee.
... mit meinem Schlafsensor, um meine Schlafen zu kontrollieren,
sowie Automationen zu fahren, wenn ich in oder aus dem Bett komme.
Was kostet das?
Wie heißt das Ding?
With Things?
Sleep?
Mattress? Nee, Sleep?
Sleep Analyzer?
Kein Sleep Analyzer, ich will einfach irgendwas,
was mir sagt, wenn man im Bett liegt.
Sleep Analyzer, Home Assistant.
Gibt es da eine Integration?
Is anyone still working on?
Ihh, über die Cloud.
Ja, das mit den Load Cells unter die Füße habe ich mir auch schon überlegt.
Das Problem ist, bei Load Cells, dass die mit dauerhafter Belastung nicht klarkommen.
Das ist eher was, oder vielleicht gibt es da auch welche.
Das ist eher was für draufstellen und dann wieder runter machen.
Load Cells mögen eigentlich in der Regen dauerhafte Belastung nicht so.
Aber okay, das ist natürlich scheiße, wie das hier gemacht ist.
Nee, das kannst du knicken.
Solange es da keine ordentliche Home Assistant Integration gibt,
kaufe ich mir sowas nicht.
Besse.
Siehste, dadurch, dass es vom Hersteller integriert ist,
wenn der Hersteller keinen Bock mehr hat, YouTube zu supporten, geht es nicht mehr richtig.
Beziehungsweise wenn es Android outdated oder sonst was.
Das ist immer die Gefahr dahinter, wenn es solche kompletten Build-In-Systeme sind.
Ich meine, warum nicht einfach ein Fahrrad dahinstellen
und sich ein Tablet vorne dran mounten selbst?
Dann ist man nicht daran gebunden.
Oder einen Fernseher hier vorne hinstellen oder so.
Alter, das ist ja auch Maximum Overkill in der Steckdose, oder?
Viel mehr geht da aber nicht mehr rein.
Das ist ja wirklich komplett, komplett dicht, Alter.
Den habe ich, genau den gleichen habe ich, das ist ein Z-Wave.
Das ist ein Z-Wave Motion und Temperatursensor.
Genau das Ding steht bei mir hinter mir im Surfer-Raum
und checkt, wenn ich die Tür aufmache.
Und sich da drin was bewegt.
Gute Idee, gute Idee.
Was für Sensoren nehmen wir die Schalter?
Irgendwelche Ami-Dinger, die man in die Wand sägt, keine Ahnung.
Gute Idee, gut, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist eine gute Idee, wenn man Angst hat, dass jemand reinkommt, während man mietet.
Das ist eine gute Idee, finde ich nice.
Oh, teuer, die Dinger sind so unverhältnismäßig teuer Nanoliefs.
Warum hat er so viel, warum hat er, ich meine er benutzt doch Home Assistant.
Warum hat er 30 Milliarden verschiedene Hubs und Apps und Geräte?
WTF?
Der will es aber wissen.
Der Konsum für 5.
So ein Ding habe ich auch, aber kein Broadlink-Button, sondern ein Aquara-Button über Zigbee.
Ein Six-Way-Switch.
Der unterscheiden zwischen Single-Press, Doppel-Press, Long-Press und Triple-Press.
Also ich könnte theoretisch 6x4 Funktionen darauf legen.
Theoretisch sogar mehrere Doppel-Press.
Ich könnte da gar nicht ausrechnen, wie viele Funktionen.
Ich verstehe, was macht er mit den, was macht er mit diesen ganzen Echo und Nest und Dings Hub Dingern?
Also warum hat er so viele, warum hat er so viele Amazon?
Redet er dann permanent damit?
Sagt er dann, wenn er am Rechner sitzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was sagt man denn da?
Hallo Echo oder Alexa sagt man dann wahrscheinlich, macht das Radio an oder was?
Warum braucht man das in jedem Raum?
Ich meine jeder wie er mag, aber...
Noch einer!
Aha.
Da müsste mal der Lockpicking-Lawyer dran.
Die habe ich auch, die habe ich, LIFX habe ich auch ein paar Dinge.
Also alle RGB-Lampen, die ich habe, sind LIFX.
Die sind zwar nicht billig, aber ich finde die sind ganz gut und sie sind Wi-Fi.
Sie brauchen keine extra Special Hubs und sowas.
Hat er das alles gesponsert bekommen? Ich würde mich nicht wundern.
Es ist mega zusammengewürfelt, er hat alles von allem in irgendwie eine Kombination.
Okay, Leute, das da ist so ziemlich die unsinnigste RGB-Lampe aller Zeiten.
Warum ist da eine RGB-Lampe einfach im Schrank, die nichts macht?
Und warum hängt da, hä? Die zwei Lampen sind ja so ziemlich die sinnlos platziertesten Lampen aller Zeiten.
Aber ich gucke das trotzdem gerne, der hat immer wieder interessante Ideen.
Zum Beispiel dieses Mal, das mit dem Motion-Sensor in der Katzenklappe finde ich ist eine richtig geile Idee.
Ja, ich auch, ich würde auch keine Voice Assistants nehmen.
Gebaited, gebaited. Please kein Kindergeschrei jetzt.
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Das meiste ist aber nicht wirklich smart.
Ich finde es ist wichtig, dass man die Sachen smart macht an den Stellen, wo es nervt.
Zum Beispiel auch eine Sache, die für mich viel mehr Wert hat, ist den NFC-Tag, den ich im Bad habe.
Ich habe den NFC-Tag am Wäsche, es war mal ein Wäschekorb, mittlerweile ist es ein Klopapierkorb.
Der Korb, wo ich die Klopapierrollen im Bad drinnen liegen habe, der hat einen NFC-Tag.
Da scanne ich mein Handy und dann geht der Heizlüfter an, damit es schnell warm wird.
Und ich habe sogar ein Video davon irgendwo, NFC.
Da! Ja, Max hallt die Klappe.
Guck da, Heizlüfter.
Ich glaube, ich muss den Sound anmachen, sonst hört man das nicht.
Die Waage geht übrigens auch bei Bluetooth direkt in den Home Assistant bei mir rein.
Okay, Max, doch nicht. Ich kann mich da nicht selbst anhören. Also da ist Heizlüfter.
Und jetzt zeige ich euch gleich den NFC-Tag, wo das Handy gescannt wird.
Ich bin ein bisschen sinnlos rum. Übrigens, Twitter-Videos sind qualitativ so schlecht und pains-champ.
Da! Wäschekorb oder besser gesagt Klopapierkorb.
Von welcher Marke sind die Server in deiner Firma?
Das meiste ist Dell. Wir haben aber auch ein paar HP und auch ein bisschen IBM.
Aber das meiste ist Dell. Guck da, das ist ein NFC-Tag. Kostet 2 Cent so ein NFC-Tag.
Gibt es für 2,20 Euro einen Pack bei Amazon. Das ist billig.
Guck, jetzt! Drangehalten und zack geht der Heizer an.
Drangehalten, zack. Heizer geht aus.
Und Heizer wieder an. Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das 10 Mal mache in dem Video.
Das ist praktisch, weil ich habe immer vergessen, wenn es richtig drückt, habe ich immer keinen Bock,
da hinten auf den Knopf zu drücken, dass der Heizer angeht. Dann flitze ich durch aufs Klo.
Und dann sitze ich auf dem Klo und denke mir, ah, ein bisschen kühl hier.
Dann halte ich das Handy an den NFC-Tag dran und der Heizer geht an.
Sehr praktisch. Sehr praktisch.
Und danach kann ich mich nebendran gleich auf die Bluetooth-Waage stellen
und Pepofat-Gewicht in Home Assistant übertragen, dass ich einen schönen Graph habe,
wie es langsam runtergeht. Oder auch nicht.
Firstworld-Problems. Ja, wir sind ja zum Glück Firstworld. Da kann man auch Firstworld-Problems haben.
Ach ja, genau. Hier ist die WLAN-Steckdose. Die haben wir übrigens zusammen im Stream geflasht, glaube ich.
Nein, mein Klo hat keine Home Assistant-Integration. Das ist zu alt.
Gut, ich glaube, mehr kommt mit dem Video nicht mehr. Ja. Da kann man auch dran ein- und ausschalten.
Ja, das war zum Beispiel was, das hat für mich echt mehr Wert gebracht.
Ist deinem Klo auch... Nein, Quatsch.
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
How to land a 100k-Job pro Jahr. Tech-Job. Fireship. Fireship macht immer gute Videos. Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Strong Mindset. Location. Master the Twitter-Game. Aha.
LinkedIn, IGiT. Übrigens, mein LinkedIn-Account ist immer noch da.
Der wird nicht... Ich weiß nicht, warum die den nicht löschen. Ich habe noch nicht mal das Passwort dafür mittlerweile.
Aber der ist immer noch da.
Benutzst du einen extra Browser, wo du angemeldet bist? Ja, ja. Ich habe einen extra Windows-Account, wo ich angemeldet bin.
Das kann man uns sonst noch angucken. Irgendjemand hat gesagt, wir sollen uns das Video vom Lost angucken.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihm jetzt noch das Elend von Battlefield 2042 geben will.
Was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl? Playstation-Emulation. Lego Gear Train. Das gucken wir jetzt. Die finde ich immer geil, die Lego-Videos.
Das NFT-Video. Stimmt, ich hatte irgendwo ein Video. What the hell are NFTs? Ich finde, der hat das echt gut erklärt.
Aber es sind 22 Minuten. 22 Minuten NFT. I can't wait.
Ich muss mir jetzt erstmal Lego-Stalls angucken. Sorry, Klemmbaustein-Stalls. Klemmbausteine, muss man ja sagen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob es wirklich Lego ist. Easy.
Ich meine, irgendwann ist dank Reibung und Widerstand ja mal Schluss.
Oh, MonkaS.
Gleich ist, gleich ist, gleich ist vorbei.
Ach nee, der hat zwei Power-Stufen oder wie?
Das erzeugt ja noch mehr Reibung jetzt oben.
Es hat wirklich seine Probleme. Es leiert schon richtig heftig.
Der Motor tut ja richtig weh, da zuzugucken.
Volle Pulle.
Okay, jetzt ist aber Schluss. Jetzt Schluss. Also mehr kann er nicht mehr gehen.
Aha, kleinere Übersetzung. Ist das kleinere Übersetzung oder größere Übersetzung?
Wie sagt man da eigentlich jetzt richtig zu? Also es hat auf jeden Fall mehr Power.
Dafür dreht es langsamer.
Okay, gleich ist Schluss. Allein schon vor der Videolänge.
Kogas, ja.
111. 111 Kogas.
Doch er hat am Motor ein kleineres angeschlossen.
Das dreht sich dreimal rum, dann sind die Batterien alle wahrscheinlich.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. 111 Zahnräder.
Mit Öl schmieren. Das wird wahrscheinlich wirklich was bringen.
Aber dann musst du die Lego-Sachen danach sauber machen.
Leute, 22 Minuten Video. Ich weiß nicht.
Oh nee, das gucken wir uns heute bestimmt nicht an.
Das ist ein zu kontroverses Thema, als dass ich mir das heute geben kann.
22 Minuten dauern hier zwei Stunden. Ja, ihr kennt mich, ihr kennt mich.
Wenn ich erstmal anfange was zu gucken und immer was dazu sagen muss, dann dauert das ewig.
Was, welches Video hat jemand ein Video gepostet?
Ich suche eine gute und billige Steckdose mit Strommesser, die man mit Tasmota flashen kann.
Das Problem ist, ich könnte dir eine empfehlen, aber die Sache ist, man weiß nicht, ob es heute noch flashbar ist.
Ich habe mittlerweile für mich die ultimative Steckdose gefunden.
Zweimal USB, kann in Strom messen und kann flashen, kann man flashen, aber die sind wahrscheinlich nicht mehr flashbar.
Die haben wir hier auch zusammen im Stream geflashed.
Die sind wahrscheinlich, wollen wir mal gucken, ob die noch flashbar sind.
Ich muss mal kurz in meiner Amazon-Historie gucken, welche das waren.
Ich gucke mal kurz.
Guck mal kurz in meine Orders-Historie.
Steckdose.
Hier, die da sind das.
Na super, kein Bild mehr, ist nicht mehr verfügbar das Produkt.
Das einzige, was ich bei mir noch habe, ist die Bestell-Historie.
Und das Ding hieß Smart, aber das ist total generic, Smart Socket mit 2 USB.
Ports, na super.
Weißt du noch jemand, die da sind das.
Ja.
Die, die sind das.
Im Prinzip ist ja auch alles re-branded China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Die sind das, die sind wirklich nice.
Ja, deswegen gibt es hier auch von 30 verschiedenen Herstellern, weil das alles nur re-brandedes Chinesen-Zeug ist.
Die sind halt cool, 2x USB, du kannst USB schalten, den Strom schalten, das kann den Strom messen, das ist gut.
Die Sache ist halt die.
Flashbar sind die nur, wenn die alte Firmware haben.
Also Over-The-Air-Flashbar, nur wenn die alte Firmware haben.
Und wenn man Pech hat, wenn man Pech hat, sind die sogar nicht mal mehr mit einem ESP32.
Und wenn er mit einem ESP62, wenn die nicht mehr mit einem ESP62 sind oder mit einem ESP32, ist mit Tasmota-Flashen eh nix.
Guck mal mal, was hier die Amazon-Dinger sagen, Störungen im Betrieb, ja, deswegen verwenden wir die ja auch nicht mit der Standard.
Nope.
Kann man nicht sagen, also es ist wirklich schwierig, es gibt kaum noch welche neue, die man Tasmota-Flashen kann, leider.
Früher-Convert, mal gucken, wann es dann das letzte Update gab, ob es da vielleicht irgendwas neues gibt.
Es gibt ja zwei Probleme, erstens, dass die neue Firmware nicht mehr sich einfach flashen lässt.
Und das zweite ist, dass sie eben gar keinen ESP62 mehr haben.
Und wenn es ein anderer Chip ist, dann funktioniert das Tasmota eh nicht.
Und das ist ziemlich kacke.
Hey, wenn da jetzt Knappheit ist, heißt das, dass mein alten Sonos...
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Ich hab auch noch so viel von dem, also nicht von den Sonos, aber von diesen ganzen Dingern hier.
Ich hab mir extra noch mal einen 5er-Pack Steckdosen-Leisten gekauft, als ich welche gefunden hab, die man Tasmota-Flashen kann.
Dass für die nächsten Jahre meine Steckdosen-Leisten-Needs erst mal abgedeckt sind.
Was macht Battlefield mit seinen Updates?
Ja nix.
Ach ja, es gibt jetzt ein Scoreboard.
Hab ich auch...
Leute, es gibt jetzt ein Scoreboard nach...
Also nein, wird es geben.
Gibt es noch nicht.
Wird es geben.
Dann gibt es die Feature, nachdem die Leute lang genug rumgemeckert haben, wieder Villen.
Die Go-Sund-Dinger sind auch nicht schlecht.
Da hab ich auch ein paar von, ja.
Go-Sund.
Ich bringe jetzt nicht den Corona-Witz zum 85.000-mal mit Geh-Sund.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Darf ich, darf ich off gehen?
Chat?
Chat ist erlaubt, darf ich off gehen?
Darf ich off gehen, wenn wir nachher noch ein bisschen Programmier-Streams machen?
Er macht nachher eh keinen Stream, er kennt mich, Leute.
Aber ich will das ausprobieren.
Ich mach wahrscheinlich tatsächlich nachher Streams.
Wir programmieren ins Welt ein Autocomplete.
Irgendjemand will das machen?
Ja.
Irgendjemand, dem ich voll, was macht mein Manager?
Ist mein Manager?
Der hat sich mega, übrigens auch mal Leute, nice, dass ihr alle rübergegangen seid beim
letzten Raid.
Er hat sich mega gefreut.
Nope.
Ist nicht on.
Er hat sich mega gefreut, dass wir ihn geradet haben.
War richtig happy.
Kannst du mal ein Stream-Video zu deinem Manjaro-Setup machen?
Hab ich schon, musste mal im Archiv gucken.
Archiv.
Wo bloß?
Manjaro.
Da haben wir, glaube ich, angefangen.
Also, guck mal, wir haben sogar zwei Streams gemacht.
Perfekt einrichten und from scratch einrichten.
Was auch immer da der Unterschied ist.
Das ist der neue, den würde ich mir angucken.
Den würde ich mir angucken.
Vier Stunden!
Wir haben seriously vier Stunden meinen Linux eingerichtet.
Alter, was ist denn da los?
Vier Stunden!
Ach so, ja, da hab ich die, den verwende ich ja gar nicht, die Schriftart.
Aber das ASCII Aquarium ist am Start.
Okay, ich hab bestimmt eineinhalb, wir haben Barbecue Pit Boys am Ende geguckt.
Okay, der Stream geht legit wahrscheinlich plus zweieinhalb Stunden oder so.
Ich find das nice, ja, tatsächlich.
Ich bin ja so View Fanboy immer gewesen, aber das Welt macht auch Bock.
Das schadet, glaube ich, nix, wenn man da ein bisschen den Überblick hat.
Über aktuelle Frontend Technologies.
Der Rest war Wunder von Flame.
Vielen Dank für den Sub.
Auch Dank an alle Subs, die ich heute vielleicht nicht gesehen habe.
Ich schau mal ganz schnell rein noch.
Creator Dashboard. Nee, hab alle gesehen. Bock, glaube ich.
Teinser hab ich schon gesehen.
Leute, die Pippo Fett.
Ich geh jetzt restlichen Nudel Spaghetti Bolognese von gestern futtern.
Wir sehen uns, bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.